That lady or gentlemen,
Hermaphrodites freaks and Geeks,
all my friends' children.
Welcome to the podcast very much once
again for tuning in.
We're here.
My Road dogs,
Eddie Bravo and mad flavor.
Let me adjust this camera because we
can't see you.
Right?
What up,
what up?
Bam.
There we go.
Tuning in.
They're tuning in.
Week number five,
week many,
many,
many weeks.
And uh,
we've been having a good fucking time.
We got a good God downtown in Boston.
And uh,
we were talking about this yesterday,
but we'll talk about it again just
because Eddie's here.
It was fucking crazy when I asked on
stage how many people listened to the
podcast.
It's like this,
the ability that you have when everybody
went crazy,
it was like this huge audience and was
like,
I'd say like 60 percent of them.
Seventy percent of them said they
listened to the podcast.
It was crazy.
So it's only going to keep doing that.
So only as long as you make things that
people think are interesting.
It's only going to like,
this is,
this is radio.
It says this,
this is just as powerful as any radio
station that's ever existed
without the bullshit and drama and all
that shit is just straight up talking.
What the fuck happened to that kid?
All right.
There we are.
I'm a terrible camera man.
Look as sharp.
Brian's off.
I'm thinking Brian is off in Ohio with
his lady friend or right?
I mean the family.
Beautiful.
How can a good God damn time getting the
free gun as far with any problems with
that?
Rob,
what's strange character?
It's funny.
You all understand Eddie Bravo in the
10th planet.
Reality Show comes to light 10th planet
Riverside,
which is respect.
It's funny because I was talking to you
on the phone last week and you said that
you went to see a shitty movie,
but you're one of the few people like
me,
that ticket shitty movie and make it
work for us.
You know what I'm saying?
Like we really make it work for us.
We see what the bad points on.
You said you watched the expendables or
whatever and it's so weird how we
learned that from Paul Mooney.
We had a conversation once about when
you're a comedian,
you should get entertained,
tell you something.
The last two weeks I've done something
that has blown me apart.
I went to see a different form of
entertainment.
I want to watch Eddie Bravo teach.
Oh yeah,
that's entertainment.
The way that place is,
the way you sit.
It's like a big fucking states.
Like if I had one man show,
I would do it there with the mats facing
everything and I still here and the
first week he taught this move where
you're hitting the guy and then you roll
and take his leg and the guy gives you
an arm so you have three different
options.
And then last week he was.
When you were there,
by the way,
you know the fucking movie.
It's got to let it go and you're hitting
them.
You're on his back.
So you take this leg and you hook double
hook on this leg and you pull over.
So he didn't take his arm from spider
web.
Oh No,
no,
no truck.
Really cool.
But just the way that he was teaching.
I hope you remember that.
Come on dog.
If I didn't want my dog was just making
shit up.
I thought you would know because in the
beginning of the DVD,
you know,
because at that point you didn't really
know the system at all.
That's the beauty of it is you were just
talking about night of the living dead
and then I flip you with the butterfly
hooks and then last week you start on
the guys back with your two hooks in the
guy in the head.
He thinks you're going to choke them out
and you flip over.
You can say you got this leg,
you hook them with that,
take it to the truck,
baby.
You got the truck.
And it was really weird how I went home
and it fucked with me that night I was
doing to accommodate it affected you?
Like if it fucked up.
Like I thought about it when I left
there and then I went the other night
which was a very simple hold where it
was controlling the guy with the under
hook,
which you're really good at.
He said George Sada Rapa is in town.
He's been in town for the last two
weeks,
so we've been focusing on over hook
butterfly stuff to rubber guard,
so,
but the point being that the situation
was that I was very intrigued while I
was watching him,
which I don't get intrigued by Dick.
I didn't go see Avatar.
All these movies don't do well when
someone's really good at tapping,
when someone's really good at something
and really good at speaking about that.
Something that's always fascinated me,
how he walks,
he keeps it.
He doesn't like a standup comic.
He walks in a certain area so people
have to look at it and he doesn't even
know what he's doing.
He doesn't know how.
Just being him,
he commands attention.
You know?
He's not a big guy.
He's not a flamboyant guy,
but I couldn't take my eyes off.
Are you gay for Eddie?
Eddie?
I'm talking about what I learned this
week,
so we just came out to us.
I'm supposed to go into the bucket.
I'm supposed to go to the theater and
see some fucking guy.
That's not funny and being at the but
those guys are funny,
but I have went to see different in
Jujitsu class and was very entertained
them was very interesting and that was
the whole point of this.
It wasn't about the UCB theater.
What the fuck is you that you really
locked me in?
And it was very,
you know,
I've ever,
you locked me in all the time.
So you know that when you're onstage you
learn something.
You know how fucking much great shit I
talk about you to everybody.
That's what I tell everybody is a
ringing all the time.
You know what I'm saying?
Everybody recognizes game business
originally with the 10th planet.
Kush.
Originally it was going to be the both
of us,
but when joe was around I'm like,
why would I want to put the fucking
camera on me and I'm just going to keep
it on jelly,
but it's.
I can't really speak my mind anyways.
I like being really honest.
I can't really do that on other people's
feelings.
I can't really be that honest and Joey
can just smash people.
I didn't say it.
I wonder if I didn't say it.
I wonder if dudes get upset at some of
your predictions.
Davis was Davis burned the kilt though.
He's got Marcus Davis.
Kenny Florian.
I fucking love you guys,
man.
You know my dogs.
You know what I'm saying?
This is our entertainment.
I didn't say shit.
No,
we just say listen to Kenny.
I picked Kenny Florian to when the
youtube clip that discussing.
Oh,
check this out,
but check this.
What we're talking about actually is
probably on youtube right now.
I uploaded it about 73.
My fucking segway.
Right?
Can we play?
No,
we can't.
We can't.
All right.
You have to have two laptops to play.
A.
Brian is not here right now.
So I barely.
I barely know what.
I'm just navigating the strip.
Even with Brian hit a fucking thing,
you know?
Okay.
But anyways,
what we're talking about this,
this review we're talking about is
actually just being released as we speak
right now.
It's 10th planet Kirsch,
episode 19 featuring Joe Rogan.
That's the one.
It's up like right this second probably.
And Joey fucking goes off and I got to
put.
I got to put like a warning thing before
this.
The views of jelly karate do not reflect
the views of Eddie Bravo.
Right.
I got to put that up.
I didn't go off.
I love.
Let me tell you something.
You'll see.
You'll see what we mean.
It was funny because I said I read
something that Dana had mentioned that
what's his name,
choked.
And I started taking about Kenny Florian
and I started taking a bite and I said,
you know what,
how can I say that about a guy that I've
never tried what he's doing,
like this is to the port and point in my
life where I'm at.
I can never say somebody choked,
you know,
maybe you had a bad day or then I
started thinking about here like six bad
days,
you know,
but I never said he choked her like
that.
All I said was I will.
I said was he was the skinniest Jesus.
Well,
people will see exactly what you said
when they watched the episode last,
but it was,
you know what?
It's all fun and what it is for the
people don't know what we're talking
about.
Joey does this break down to the UFC as
joey karate,
who's a Cuban black belt and it's
probably even if you're not a UFC fan,
it's probably the funniest fucking
thing.
You walk in the Internet,
the funniest possible,
most entertaining reviews of UFC
previews and review.
Sometimes we review a show.
Sometimes there's is nothing out there.
Fuck Espn,
fuck all that shit.
There's no body that brings the fire
like Joey.
All that Shit's entertaining to a point,
but I don't know how many times I
fucking turned it off halfway through
mma live and half.
It's just,
it's when you hear joey do it,
fuck you want it to last 30 minutes and
I'm always find three or three and three
might pick some money.
You understand it because I've learned
from these guys and I know what it is to
get beat up.
So I watched these fights and that's how
I picked the things that I've been like
two other three lately with the two key
matchups always been money,
so I'm not that fucking bad.
No,
you're very good.
You're very accurate with it.
I don't want him to see that many guys
talking about fights and analyzing
fights,
you know,
I don't like.
There's not a lot of guys I like to
listen to.
Yeah.
You know what I,
you know,
I respect everybody out there doing to.
Personally I don't get nearly as much
insight from the,
from like any articles or any
commentators I get it from,
from mma forums I think do have more
opinions and better opinions and points
of view on MMA forums.
Yeah,
and there's some very good writers as
you're right on the underground,
there's guys who are running the
underground,
you read their shit and like this guy is
a fucking author.
I mean you might as well be writing for
a magazine.
This is like really well written,
a really well written breakdown of the
event of,
of a guy's performance.
That to me,
I just because a guy has a job with
Yahoo,
does it make them more credible than
mcfuck stick one on the underground?
They're just human beings just right and
they need to be official on ESPN DOT
com.
To me,
I'm a interacting with people in the
underground and getting someone's
opinion.
You get a bit more insight as to how
fights going to go down from that and I
think than any of the websites online,
you know,
the one time I do like hearing what a
fighter actually has to say about a
fight the one time when they're talking
about stuff that the public and me
included really don't know about what's
really going on in that fucking cage.
You know what I mean?
Very few people experience fighting in
front of the fucking world.
So when a guy is breaking down a fight
and they see something,
a chink in that guy's armor,
like he folds or you know,
like maybe fighters can after awhile
some fighters are known as folders,
right?
They just fold under the pressure,
you know,
and I'm a fighter,
see that quicker than the average
person.
So I like that kind of incentive.
Yeah.
There was a time when I was doing
commentary with Randy and I'm a dude got
poked in the eye and the referee went
over to him and he said,
Kenya,
see?
And he's like,
man,
I dunno,
I dunno.
10.
Randy got angry.
Randy goes,
you never tell them you can't see.
He goes,
if he tells him he can't see it means he
doesn't want to fight.
And I was like,
whoa.
He got like really intense,
like his crazy,
like,
you know,
a competitive drive came out when he was
discussing this other guy.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
That's my plan.
I don't want to hear like a bunch of
analysts to sit around going,
what are you going to do?
Is Click weird.
Has Go to keep the folks turned and shut
up.
Shut up.
Stop it.
I want to hear you want to call Mama
Man,
the caveman.
Geico.
Take down ground and pound.
It's all happening,
dog.
You ain't stopping it.
That's what I want.
I want to hear that kind of stuff.
I do enjoy inside amendment though.
I watch that shit all the time because
I'd run into some core fighter.
I'm a bus route and fat fucking to the
test article in the craziest way.
You know what I mean?
Pause is insane.
It's an insane man.
Hosts the fucking show.
It's hilarious.
We flew to Boston on the same plane.
We're on the same flight as fuck.
One of the nicest guys I've ever met is
super crazy nice.
But he's also crazy so on the planet.
Right.
So bosses on the plane and he goes up to
use the restroom and one of the ladies
that's working for the plane is like,
do you,
are you here for the wrestling thing?
You,
you know?
And he's like,
uh,
yeah,
it's mixed martial arts.
We're there for mixed martial art,
you know,
he's talking to and she tells him that
her husband has hands that he or her
boyfriend,
his hands that he had registered as a
deadly weapon and boss became obsessed
with this bus is like,
this is not true.
You know,
I told her bullshit,
you know,
boss is telling me that he told her
bullshit.
We get off the plane.
He was still telling.
She's telling me her boyfriend's hands
are registered as a deadly weapon.
I'm like,
no fucking way.
It was like super amped up about this.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I listened to some of the shitty set on
my God,
he's got like at least 15 to 20 classic
lines like you want to put that shit on
a loop and then on top of this crazy
shit,
bad ass fighter.
I mean he was one of the,
one of the premier strikers in MMA
during his era,
like when he took out two Yoshiko Soka
wash that fucking fight.
Watch that fight where he wanted the
title.
He's a bad motherfucker don't.
That was actually one of the title.
That was the first fight he had in the
UFC on the posters that said the world's
greatest martial artists.
That's how they were bringing him in as
the world's greatest martial artists.
And pause just fucked up to Yoshi Osaka.
Just blast and him like.
There wasn't very many dudes who were
striking like that in the UFC,
but is fucking tough.
The toughest fuck boss was a savage man.
His He's attack man.
He could kick so fucking hard.
I man,
when he first brought and pancreas,
all these dudes were kind of doing the
same kind of thing.
The pancreas is the open hand slaps,
you weren't allowed to punch and there's
a lot of dudes that weren't kicking very
good.
They just were kinda like,
they take a guy down and dive on leg
locks because they all these shin pads
and these shoes on,
like you can grab a hold of a dude's
feet pretty easy and a lot of dudes were
doing leg locks,
boss route and came out of nowhere
blasting dudes with kicks.
Just uhm,
you would see them hit these guys.
They'd be like,
what the fuck is he doing?
And the palm strikes these Japanese
guys,
they didn't have that.
We just slapping each other and
grappling.
He said,
wait a minute,
we could slap.
How about a fucking slap you really
fucking hard.
So he came in and he was fucking iron
palming.
What he was doing was boss could pull
his hand way back.
So he was basically just punching you
with this.
He was using all his punch techniques,
but he was hitting you with the,
the,
you know,
the meat of your hand,
which really is better because it
doesn't hurt your knuckles.
Your hands don't break.
You can hit some shit really hard like
that.
He was not going to not allow what these
slabs.
The japs were crush anybody out.
But upper cut slaps knocking dude
senseless.
You know what's crazy is I went to
Amsterdam with boss route in 2011.
I commentated for a show called too hot
to handle and Holland while I was
working for King of the cage and pride
I've fucking hired me.
So we're all on the same flight.
We're all in st flight.
He lived in La and this is when he was
crazy as fuck.
I'm not going to get into detail what
happened.
I don't want to bus them out,
but he's known as a crazy wild man.
Yes.
On the fucking plane was a crazy wild
men on the plane and I can't get into
details but God dammit when we get to
and we partied all fucking.
I was.
I have about 100 pictures of me and all
fucked up in Holland.
I can't even begin to tell you.
Do you remember any of it?
I remember all of it.
Well,
I remember a lot of shit thanks to
pictures because we took a lot of
pictures and then you watch the pictures
of us.
How your memories become memories of the
pictures.
You actually remember that those are
your memories.
The picture.
Well,
memories are okay.
Relevant.
You know if you use them,
if it's a memory that's never going to
come up.
It's really hard to retrieve if it
doesn't have any emotional like bearing
in your life.
Like I have memories from my early
childhood because they were like strong
moments.
That meant something to me.
I learned something from that experience
but like a regular memory just hanging
out with somebody.
How long do you remember that?
For?
Good memories.
I remember a lot of shit.
As I get older I feel like I have less
room on my hard drive.
I feel like I got an old hard drive dump
stuff,
but I do remember the important stuff.
I got a question for you,
Joe.
What do you think out of everything
you've heard and about pancreas?
I mean,
what do you think?
I don't know what to think,
but Ken Shamrock told me,
Ken Shamrock told me,
came out of his mouth and all those
pancreas fights were worked.
Never set up except except for when
foreigners fought each other.
They would just let them fight.
Wow.
That's when it was Japanese against a
foreigner.
Like he said he was.
He actually worked for the Japanese.
He was in pancreas as their American to
fight so they can mix it in with the
European.
That's what he said.
He said,
I was brought in.
You got to be really good at the same
time because he said he was.
You had to be really,
really good because you had to,
you know,
if you had to have.
They asked you to take them to the later
rounds or whatever,
take them late into the fact you got to
be good enough to.
Cause sometimes the foreigners didn't
know they were fixed.
He said the foreigners didn't always
know,
but we would control it like we were.
So the foreigners,
you'd have to make sure just didn't
knock them out.
He sounded with him that we're trying to
create characters and do different shit.
What they do with the phone or got hurt.
Did this is just all.
I don't know if this is true or not.
I don't know about gambling.
Is that what it is?
I Dunno,
but it's fights.
I mean,
if it's all about predicting the
outcome.
Is it like pro wrestling with fighting?
I think it was.
I think it was a half pro-wrestling half
real.
You know what I mean?
I think that's a pancreas,
but I don't know.
Man.
This is what Ken shamrock.
I don't know.
I wouldn't know.
I wouldn't know it because I do know one
thing that fucking frank shamrock
against Alan goes,
that shit was real.
That was pancrase was.
And that was real as fuck.
Do you remember that at all?
Alan goes was all over frank shamrock.
You could if you grabbed the rope,
if you got to let go of the hold and
start again.
So you're a fucking hold of.
You can grab the rope.
So Alan goes,
was over frank shamrock.
Thanks.
I'm like,
just started greg.
He had,
she was so green,
he really didn't know Jujitsu that well.
He was just a real natural athlete,
powerful,
strong.
He was always explosive.
He was just a fitness fucking
powerhouse.
And he knew some,
some,
some shit from Ken Shamrock,
but he wasn't that good at that point.
And Alan goes,
was all over him and if it wasn't for
the ropes he would've fucking um,
but at the end,
frank shamrock guide them in a fucking
foot lock dude and goes,
couldn't reach the any fucking jacked
him and broke his ankle.
Really?
Yeah.
But it was like a draw I think.
I don't remember exactly if there were,
if it was a disqualification,
I don't know.
There was something at the end.
I don't know who won,
but I do know Alan gross was all over
him,
but he got saved at Frank Shamrock.
I'm saving the ropes.
And then at the end he got them in an
ankle lock man and an allen goes,
didn't defend ride and he broke it.
He screams,
screams.
Oh,
surprised that frank shamrock retired.
I was surprised commentator for the
strikeforce,
but he hasn't retired.
He said he retired.
He had a big,
a big dude.
He retired.
He had a big ceremony,
stood in the middle of the octagon and
about how many times as he retired.
Many times I'll honest.
Exactly.
Farewell Tours.
Technically he's had several farewell
tour,
barrel.
Okay,
so you think,
can you think frank shamrock getting in
that cage,
just bow and everybody's just publicity
stunt,
but eventually he's going to come back
and make it.
Look.
It's a really big deal.
Who's coming back?
I'm not going to say it was a publicity
stunt because maybe he believes he's
really retiring,
but I believe and he hasn't made that
much money.
He hasn't made that much money and you
have all these boxes that have made
gazillions and boxing and happens all
the time.
All of these five bucks than lead
because though you get used to the
money.
Damn.
If I fight again,
that could fight for like,
dude,
I can make $500,000.
That means a lot to these guys.
These guys aren't rich will come back.
You know what I mean?
How will always come back?
I think he's coming up.
He's in his late thirties,
I believe he's about 37.
You know,
he even guys with millions come back for
the money and he didn't make no.
Well,
he's a smart guy though.
He hadn't to them.
I'm not saying this,
I'm not saying he's.
I think he could do anything and I think
if he decides that he doesn't want to
compete anymore,
why should you compete?
If it's not as hard anymore and he feels
like his performances reflect that,
why not just step down?
Why not stop doing it?
If you can get over it.
The real problem with fighters is at a
certain point in time,
your self esteem and your self worth
evolves completely around your ability
to fight and beat people up and when you
can't do it anymore,
you feel like a loser.
You know?
A lot of guys,
they don't even know who they are when
they stopped competing because it's such
an intense experience that a giant chunk
of their life is dedicated to getting
really good at it,
to getting good at fighting.
Their whole life revolves around their
fighting and then when they're not
fighting,
it's like they're lost.
Like when I was doing comedy and I was
sucking,
one of the best things that happened to
me is I tore my acl and the reason being
is I couldn't train.
I couldn't do anything and I certainly
couldn't fight and I needed an
operation,
but it took competing as an option away
from me.
I was 21 years old and it took it away.
Now I was like,
I can't compete anymore,
but my legs fucked.
Okay,
so now I do have to concentrate in the
next phase of my life because otherwise.
The thing about martial arts was,
this is the only thing I'd ever done
that was I was good at.
So I would do other things that suck
out.
I'm like,
but I'm good at this.
What the fuck am I doing?
Why am I,
why am I,
why am I getting away from this?
My brain would be like,
you don't want to do something.
It'd be terrible at it.
Do something to be good at it,
even if there's no fucking money in it.
No future in it,
you know,
you,
you can get really,
really,
really attached to the,
of who you are and being a fighter,
it's very difficult for those guys to
step away.
You know,
you can call it the glory.
Everybody says the glory.
It's far more complicated than that.
It's who they are.
It's all of a sudden their life is not
wrapped around training camps and
preparing and improving your skills to
face the next level and to get to the
top and you get your title back once
you've lost it and you know,
it's not that anymore.
Now it's just,
you're just a regular dude.
Well,
if you were just a regular dude,
there's nothing sad about being a
regular dude,
but I guess if you're a fighter and
you'd go to become just being a regular
dude,
for a lot of them,
it's just too much to handle.
They don't want them to normal life.
They're wired for fucking craziness.
No,
they're wired for that extreme
experience.
That shit's hard to walk away from it,
Huh?
I mean,
nothing could feel better than beating
someone's like winning the belt in the
UFC
main card when chocolate domains those
arms back.
And I mean,
what feels better than that?
Yeah.
I mean we're the number one guy on the
planet.
Chuck would do that.
Throw his arms back.
It looks like he's got like the whole
fucking like he should be going,
right?
Yeah.
Like there's like a lightening bolt.
Of course you get addicted the Bat.
You need that though.
When he smashed Tito in,
you know,
and after it was over,
he was so fired up because Tito had
talks so much shit.
Chuck is like the nicest guy in the
world,
but if you talk shit,
chuck Liddell is the last person you
want to talk shit because he just wants
to take it out on you.
He wanted to take it out on Tito's so
bad.
And when he knocked him out and he
fucking threw his arms back,
like you could literally,
it was like,
it was like that.
It was like a black hole was opening up.
Do you get there?
When did I tell you this story?
About a checklist,
Dell party in and Dana Dana's lawyer or
something,
grabbing some chicks ass.
They tell that story and all that shit.
Should you be telling us?
Um,
I don't know the guy's name.
And so it doesn't matter.
It was just a guy.
So.
Well,
did he do something that can get them in
trouble?
No,
no,
no.
What happened is where we're at some
club in vegas excess or some shit and
it's like Dana Lorenzo,
Chuck's.
They're like,
man,
this guy that's got on top of the lawyer
Guy,
one of.
They have a bunch of lawyers.
So a lawyer for something.
A little guy.
He's all sitting there.
We're all at a table and right next to
the next table is straight baller.
Like he had to be a rapper or like.
Because he was a straight making it rain
on what?
It was funny he was.
Wait a minute,
dude,
that was there.
This guy that got mouthy with chuck?
Yes.
Remember he started throwing up.
It was funny.
He was the dude next to us was throwing
up ones.
The ones with landing on our table,
we have billionaires there.
Nobody's picking up the phone to me
once.
They're just all over our feet.
Make it because it's just so.
Anyways,
I got loud and mouthy.
No,
no,
no.
That.
He had a of girls in that the rapper
guy,
it was just him by himself with a bunch
of chicks at his table and we're right
next to him and I'm sitting there like
looking at all the girls going,
God damn,
there's this guy has got a lot of girls.
Like what the,
what does he do?
Right.
And I think,
I think I don't know what he was an
athlete or something probably so coke
and the lawyer that was sitting next to
me and we're both looking over.
We're both looking over at all the
chicks and I'm going,
God damn,
he's got some hot ones.
And the lawyer guy reaches over at 13.
One grabs the chicks ass and the girl
turns around and goes,
who the fuck did that?
And the lawyer pointed at me.
He said,
me,
I go,
Whoa,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You keep up this guy's name,
who I don't know his name.
I don't know.
I don't have no idea who he was,
but he was with.
He was with everybody.
Just grab the girl's ass and then the
girl goes,
who grabbed my ass?
He goes,
he pointed at me.
I go,
dude,
fuck you.
I didn't grab no girl's ass.
Fucking point.
He pointed at me.
Right,
so find who this guy is.
So that girl grabs the fucking athlete.
Dude comes over and he gets right in his
fucking face and he's right there
saying,
did you get the guy keeps trying to
shake it.
Lawyer guy tries to shake his hand,
goes like,
fuck you shake it out.
You grab her fucking asshole.
Fuck your prayer.
He's like running this place because let
me shake your hand.
Let's,
let's,
let's talk.
Fuck your hand man.
Fuck your hand.
And he goes,
let's just talk this because I'm going
to fuck you up right here.
And then why this is happening.
Fucking Patrick Calls Chuck or Dana
calls or Lorenzo,
one of them they call chuck chuck just
hanging out on the other side of the
table.
He looks over the go.
Chuck handle that Shit,
Chuck.
Weird fucking too.
He went right into that guy's face.
So what the fuck you going to do?
He didn't even know what the fuck
happened and the guy starts going trying
to shape chuck's hand.
Chuckles.
Fuck you.
Fuck with anybody here.
I'm going to fucking kill you.
It did.
I wait a minute.
You show that.
That's what he said because you weren't
right there though.
I was there with screaming at them.
Yeah.
And the guy was trying to shake chucks
and chuck was like,
I'll chuck since it seemed to me a
little bit more,
less intense than that.
The guy was definitely very aggro,
but chuck did get in his face to chuck
out riding.
Shut them down,
fucking registered with the FBI.
There's only black guys in that cousin.
Do you ever noticed that white karate
guys and that was.
That didn't exist when I was a kid
growing up.
If you were black and you will talked
about Bruce Lee was always that black
guy.
I said,
listen,
I got a cousin who's a black belt who's
got his,
has registered with the tail,
actually have your hair.
Only black guys have used exactly maybe
20 years ago.
I think if you had a.
I think if you had a black belt in
karate and some states still your hand.
I say that's ever been the case,
but you never heard about that.
I've heard about that.
People heard about it,
but it's not real.
It's just things that people make up.
I don't think there's any place that
makes you register.
Your hands is deadly weapon closet.
Almost positive 100 percent we got on.
It was very short.
This is not true.
No.
It just looked very upset.
What professional fighter and something
ever goes down.
You always lose because that's the case.
That's not necessarily the case.
That's Roger Work at thing.
Everybody thinks he was in the right.
That guy that knocked out that chicken.
Things have changed now I think 20 years
ago.
That was something.
There was some states that's a video.
There's a video of that guy being an
aggressive douche bag.
So is that.
That's where the evidence has card off
in Texas?
Yeah.
Well the guy,
the guy punched this chicken the face
like it's the beginning of the video and
the guy just whoever's filming it looks
like he just got lucky and caught this
on tape.
But this big black dude,
he's a fucking like a quarter.
What's going on here?
Just hold it like a mic.
No,
not in the mood.
I hope a relaxing big big guys like 2:50
fucking giant muscles walks up to this
chicken.
Just blasts or in the face and sucker
punched her.
And everybody's like,
what the fuck?
But the dude so big,
nobody wants to do anything.
Well Roger character gets right up to
the guy who goes,
hey man.
And he's got his hands up like this man
band.
You just knocked out girl.
And the guy's like,
I'm not got any pitch at one.
I'm not your bitch ass out.
And the guy took his shirt off.
So Roger where that goes.
All right.
I guess we're going,
Brad,
where he takes his shirt off and there's
a lot of scrambling the camera.
It's tough to see what's going on,
but seconds later,
maybe four,
maybe five,
the dudes unconscious on the ground and
roger were just beaten down on him.
Just Blab,
blab.
I mean,
it's like Karma,
like a movie.
It's like a.
he's an action hero.
He's like Spiderman.
He just blast this dude out of nowhere
and they all got it on video and you
can't say anything because the guy hit a
check.
It's like the perfect scenario is like,
here's a guy using his martial arts for
good.
Unquestionably.
I mean,
he's in a place where a guy assaults a
woman and does it,
hits her with a sucker punch.
He confronts the man with his hands up
in a passive way like this.
Like,
hey man,
what the fuck?
You just knocked out a girl like,
surely it's got to be a reason for this,
you know?
Uh,
yeah,
that girl killed my mother.
You know what I'm saying?
You know,
you never know.
He's like,
I'm not a bitch ass.
I want,
I'm not your bitch ass out to roger were
to kick his ass and it's all on video.
I love it.
Roger worth the captain.
Save a hoe.
Fuck.
Love it.
Give him a Cape right now.
It's over.
I don't think he meant to do and I think
he couldn't help himself.
You know that guy went through a lot of
abuse when he was a kid.
He's a,
he's very sensitive to bullies.
I think when he sees a situation like
that,
it's like you have to step in and do
something like that girl just got
punched.
I mean even if it was for a reason,
what could it have been?
I mean,
what's,
what's the reason to walk up to a
chicken sucker?
Punch.
Drown your puppy.
What the fuck?
The is it.
There's no reason why.
What I sucker punch a check.
Let me think.
She would have had to have the keys to
the nuclear bombs.
She was writing.
She stole my fucking phone.
I would fuck if she's still on my phone.
I would sacrifice.
Really.
That's all tanks.
A girl has to steal your phone and
you'll sucker punch your fucking.
Wow.
You're very close with your phone.
He loves his phone.
Now.
Make my laptop,
my laptop.
Maybe my phone.
I would.
I would like push your head.
What's the.
You've been without a phone and without
Internet connection.
What's the longest time?
Woo.
A man.
A T and t is will lied.
Saying they suck locally.
A T and t sucks balls at my house.
We can't talk on the phone at my house.
It's kind of weird and,
but God damn it that it'll come on in
Thailand on a fucking island off the
coast of Thailand.
My God.
Damn.
It's working.
I guess the roaming or something,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know what it is,
but I went to a,
um,
a resort once in Mexico in Cancun.
I wanted to go see the Mayan ruins.
We went to a teacher needs,
uh,
and uh,
the resort that we went to,
we stayed up near Cancun.
No telephones,
no Internet access,
no television,
nothing.
There was nothing.
It was terrible.
I got movies to watch on my laptop.
I'm watching movies on my laptop,
my laptop,
Kennedy connect to the Internet.
You're running out of time,
man.
I like watching a little TV.
It doesn't matter where I'm staying,
how beautiful it is when I lie down in
bed.
I like to see what the fuck's going on
in the world.
Turned on CNN for a few minutes.
Last week I made a mistake.
I had one of the house phone,
so I called a t and t terry called the
and t.
We got everything put together.
The DSL,
the hospital.
Well,
they hooked everything up except they
shut the dsl off for five days.
Just show them the VSL,
the dialogue.
No Internet.
Dial up all my God.
After one day I was like,
fuck it.
If I just read it out,
I didn't bust down and go to the library
and I'll tell you what by the third day
it was kind of fucking nice.
Really kind of rely on emails that I get
stressed so much.
Five days try for five days,
no cell phone.
See what your life.
You don't want Brock Lesnar does that
shit sometimes.
You really got to think about it.
You really got,
and I know,
I know you're in a position where you
need your cell phone.
Okay,
well listen man,
there's a.
obviously I agree with you.
That's why I moved to the mountains.
It's something about it.
I really enjoyed it.
I think being a seperate,
just having a little time to yourself is
very important.
Very important book.
I mean I'm a huge proponent of the
isolation tank and that's the whole
theory behind lives.
Slips and tank being alone completely
did in 98 memory.
I was going out psycho.
His girlfriends always have the best
name again.
Board again was one,
psychos and other psycho.
Um,
we're,
we're at the tail end of the
relationship.
It was falling apart and we decided
let's try to rekindle our love and drive
up the coast of Monterey.
It's try it once,
see what happens.
One final fucking go at it.
Right?
So we drove up and it was pretty fucking
cool.
Getting high,
driving up the fucking pch.
The view was amazing.
I didn't realize the first time ever I
drove up,
I didn't realize how beautiful the cause
of credible.
The view is incredible all the way up
the coast.
It's like I kept pulling over a minute
though.
I kept looking at him like she's all.
I'm like,
I got a video tape this.
This is like fucking heaven.
It's so close to the edge though.
That road that road's scary as fuck.
It's like you could easily just turn,
just decide.
This is it.
I'm going to end it.
Turned to the right and you're.
You're off the side of the cliff.
Oh,
oh,
scary.
Fuck you.
That's scary.
And you're trusting the other person
coming the other direction.
You try trusting you to not be crazy and
suicide.
So we're driving up the coast.
We go up to Monterrey.
It's fucking cool.
We go to the aquarium video tape and
shit.
I'm like,
fuck man,
why am I having a good time with her?
This is nice,
right?
Smoking weed the whole time and then we
spend a couple of days and Manoa.
It was cool.
It was getting a little boring.
It was getting a little boring,
but I'm like,
okay,
we were going to drive back down and
there's a place,
it's like the wilderness next to the
beach on clips.
It's called big surfer and you rent
little bungalows and we're going to rent
bungalows for two nights,
like fuck and go hiking and then hiked
to the beach.
Fuck.
It's amazing.
It's fucking paradise.
We get there.
We check in for two nights.
Pam,
we immediately,
we go hiking and shed.
We had been in Monterrey for a couple of
days.
We go to the beach.
Fuck,
I got that all.
It's like some magical shit.
And then van that Sun was coming down
and we go back to the bungalow and we
didn't know.
They didn't have anything.
They didn't have radio,
TV,
nothing.
They had nothing straight up.
So we were like,
oh shit.
So it's like 7:30
and we're kicking back.
There's nothing to do.
So we watched the last two days at
Monterey on the little lcd screen on our
quarter.
We're watching that and I'm thinking
there's only 90 minutes of this.
It was,
it was.
I was beginning to see.
We fucked,
you know,
she first time ever we videotaped it.
It was like,
there was like,
whoa.
The first time we've ever videotaped sex
while we just,
we didn't,
we ran out of shit to do and now it's
like 9:30
and shit.
Holy Fuck.
It was.
I realized something that how important
TV and internet is,
especially when you're,
you know,
I could just go to sleep or whatever,
but when you're trying to entertain your
girlfriend,
I said,
fuck it.
I went back to,
I went to the front desk and I said,
I didn't know that we didn't.
There was no reception up here at all.
Can we get,
can I get a refund for tomorrow?
I just want to leave that next morning,
get the fuck back.
So I came back and I go,
guess what?
I said,
why did I go?
I go,
I got the refund for tomorrow night.
She goes,
yes,
she wanted the fuck out until.
I was like,
fuck out of here.
We're just lying though.
There's nothing to do.
We were already,
we've heard each other's stories for the
last six months.
Like what are you going to tell me a new
story about?
Here's the problem.
Knew about you man,
when you first meet someone hanging out
with them for 10 hours in a row and just
talking is easy.
We broke up.
I know on the way back she was in a bad
mood.
Like we started fighting.
I'm like,
it's fucking over.
By the time I hit fucking Santa Barbara,
I was like,
okay,
thanks again as the exit plan.
You know what I mean?
It was done.
Kept your relationship together and I
realized,
Oh shit,
we didn't have shit.
By the time I hit Santa Barbara and
Ventura fucking.
I was like,
planning for the future.
No.
Without her you had fucking.
And sometimes that's enough to keep a
relationship together for a.
We watched a lot of TV together.
If we didn't have tv,
what the fuck would we do to get them
back?
Nowadays a couples couples like I went
to my friend's house,
Steve from a,
you know.
Sure.
Steve Miley from La fight here.
Him and his girlfriend,
they got the big screen going and
they've both got their laptops on their
post every time I go over there watching
some movie on our laptop too and it's
like that's the fucking wave of the
future right there.
Right?
Well,
yeah,
if you're in that kind of relationship.
Yeah.
You know what?
You just were hanging out with you but
we got shit to do,
but we're still hanging out.
We're still right here.
I could kiss you and all that,
but I got works.
Chicks,
they want to be watching the same thing
though.
I don't want you in the room while they
watch a movie and cuddle.
How you got to watch cuddling.
Why while you're watching the movie
club.
Fuck the people on top of me yet I don't
a bucket,
but by love cuddling night,
late night when I'm watching like
fucking use somebody to get my nokia.
Nobody.
Yeah,
you're right.
You can't.
I can't.
You know I have.
I don't like that.
I like to ween myself off of shit.
Especially the last five or six years.
Right?
There's nights I don't sleep with the
sleep apnea machine as even though I
know I'm going to get a headache.
What if there's an earthquake?
What if?
I always want to prepare myself and
that's why I don't like this shit.
These fucking luxuries guy.
That's why I was the last guy to get a
fucking cell phone.
You know it.
You broke my balls for three years about
it.
Something about something about it.
You know what?
That pager,
what I call somebody and they have a
cell phone than Atlanta pisses me off
because it's not a house phone.
It's a cell phone.
It's in your pocket.
You miserable.
Mother answered the fucking thing.
You know what I'm saying?
And that's why I don't like cell phone
because I like to get people.
I call them or they'll say,
let me look at your cell phone and smash
it because that's what.
It's a luxury and to the fucking thing.
It's the same thing with these fucking
computers.
You've got to get on.
Especially you.
You're an intelligent.
Get off this shit for five days and see
how different your fucking life is.
I enjoyed it after the second day I was
like,
God damn.
It's like I was on coke.
I had to go somewhere every 20 minutes
to do a bump.
That's what I feel like when I'm on the
computer.
Every time I'm home I got to stop what
I'm doing every 30 minutes and see who
emailed me or whatever.
It's really nice that they give a fuck.
Like,
you know what would be nice.
I agree with you,
but I actually actually enjoy the
business when I get into mode and I
gotta know I to answer all my emails.
Joint letter and I'm like,
pop,
pop.
What?
I read a letter from time to time.
I hand write a letter just to fucking
keep me alive.
Door both depends on the shit.
You know what?
Let me ask you something if right now,
if I took your fucking phone and I asked
you what's your mother's number was?
You wouldn't fucking know it.
Neither would I.
we're getting too fucking comfortable
guys.
Take your phone.
I smash it.
You're going to sit there scratching
your lunch for two days.
You know,
three numbers in your head,
the house,
your manager,
and that's it.
You don't know nobody else's number.
The only number I know,
but I didn't even know that number and I
haven't lost your last one away for
three days.
That's why they call you in Boston.
Last numbers.
You can store in your brain.
Me,
anybody in the old days because of my
cocaine in my criminal shit.
I don't want numbers written on paper.
Never wrote papers when my mother died,
my sister anymore because my mom had all
those numbers in their head.
You know Jay z does those wraps in his
head and on paper.
It's in your fucking head,
man.
That's kind of crazy.
That's insanity.
But you do need a paper from time to
time.
Don't time where I didn't write any of
my comedy.
Don't believe he don't.
He don't use a paper.
You got to write shit like a
motherfucker.
I'll forget.
You know there's.
I forgot,
man.
What I think has happened in Joey
is much more complicated than that.
I think it's not that this is making us
soft.
I think this is becoming a part of us
and you leave your phone at home and I
leave my phone at home and I go out and
I realized I don't have my phone on me.
I feel naked.
Something's wrong.
Yeah.
I feel connected.
Vulnerable.
I feel vulnerable.
You walk in your door,
you pick up your phone and I called you
big fucking deal.
It feels.
Feels good about it.
Think about when you walk in,
you haven't had your phone and you open
it up and you think all this is all this
knowledge is going to be in there,
and I think it's nostalgia for the past.
I think we're moving towards an era
where you don't remember phone numbers
there on this device that controls
everything in your life and it might
even be a part of your body.
I think what we're,
you know,
you can't hold onto the past where
things are changing.
They're obviously changing in our
lifetime.
The Internet has made things radically
different.
Just in our lifetime.
We have had more change in our lifetime
then hundreds and hundreds of years in
the past.
Just in a few decades,
I think this all this computer and
technology and shit,
so I'm making a soft.
It's becoming a part of us and it's
gonna.
It's gonna.
I think in some way it's going to help
human beings evolve.
Well,
two years from now when the average
bombed the fucking power,
the satellites,
we got no fault and you're stuck on
fucking trying to call me fucking.
I had a fucking know joey's number that
everybody,
at least in my worries,
when the world ends because no,
I didn't tell her about the world and
he's listened.
They they'd been trying to hit you.
Ain't gonna have no lines.
When the world ends,
there's no full need to know how to with
your shoelace.
I understand they'll kill a rabbit.
That's why I'm getting ready for next
year.
That's why.
That's why I hang out with the brothers
and Vermont and shoot.
We're going to go hunting with Ricky
Schroder.
We're going to make it a reality.
So Eddie Bravo,
me and Ricky Schroder out hunting.
I'm the only animal I've ever killed was
if you count,
set up a mouse trap and he killed
another man.
That's the only thing I'm going to be
down for that though,
right?
Go hunting with Ricky Schroder.
Fuck.
We should film that.
Right.
Come on over and get a rifle.
That would be interesting.
You and I super baked in the woods with
guns.
What a great idea.
If I was really high,
I think it would be better at him.
I'm just kidding.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I wouldn't be high with a gun.
The same woods as other people.
I would not do that.
He can't do the rubber gloves to go to.
One is fucking.
You have to be very careful.
I read this article online about.
I was researching hunting in the hunting
exits in Maine because,
uh,
I was,
I used to have this joke about hunting
in Maine and I was like,
I wonder what the real numbers were like
how many people actually got shot.
Well,
the real problem is experienced hunters.
They literally see deer,
they'll see a deer and they'll pull the
trigger and then after they pulled the
trigger,
they realize it's a woman in a red
jacket.
It's like it's their mind plays tricks
on them because a seasoned hunter has to
get so good at recognizing movement.
There he is.
I got the opening poem,
pulled the trigger so their brain
literally puts an image of a deer in
front of them.
When they see motion,
your brain tries to already give you the
image before it even gets it because
you're looking for it for it so bad that
your brain makes you visualize a deer.
There's the deer and these guys
literally say they saw a deer and the
most horrible night.
How often does that happen?
All the time.
Really?
Yeah.
That's a problem and the problem is
experienced hunters,
experienced hunters who just.
They're just used to knowing that you
have to capitalize on,
on on a quick opening.
There's the opening thing.
I'm not going to person like that Shit's
real,
man.
That's the scariest thing about hunting
hunters that don't know what the fuck
they're doing and people accidentally
shooting people.
It happens all the time.
You got to experience.
Hope is out there.
Thirty percent and the other is an
experience.
So some motherfuckers going to get shot
with.
The article that I was reading was about
this guy who was an investigator and he
was out there,
uh,
you like investigating people who were
shot and you know,
they had this one guy that he was a
suspect and the guy wasn't experienced
hunter and he just,
you know,
was asking the guy like,
hey,
you know,
you see anything or anything going on,
we've got a situation.
And the guy's like,
no,
no good.
See anything.
All he did was just drive by the dude's
house everyday for a week.
Just pause in front of the house,
stop looking at them.
Drive four or five days later,
the dude who just couldn't take it
anymore.
Imagine the guilt of accidentally
shooting somebody while you're hunting.
You know,
you think you've seen a deer.
So I talked to the guy and that's what
the guy said once he finally confessed,
he said,
I really thought it was a person.
I mean I really thought it was an
animal.
I saw an animal.
I saw the horns,
I saw the whole thing.
I saw buck with a big rack and I pulled
the trigger and it was a person.
Let's go do that tape.
Bit cost suckers.
That's what I want to go home.
I want a hug.
You can't eat them man.
I don't want to eat a fucking.
I don't even want to tell my animals
like crazy.
Yeah.
But I don't want to eat something.
Light shot.
Oh,
I see.
Why not?
Don't you want to see that fucking hold
his head.
Why would you want the animal to die in
some fucking factory farm?
Or they get their brain smashed by a
piston and you know,
they're,
they're living in cow shit all day for
most of their life until that happened.
I just don't want to shoot him that.
You know what?
I don't want to either,
but I eat meat and I love it.
I had a juicy fat fucking steak last
night.
It was wonderful to meet.
Now what?
I love it.
I think it's a part of being a human
being.
I love Pussy,
but you don't see me.
Shoot me.
Shoot a pitch of the head with it.
Even though I would love it.
I just don't want to shoot an animal.
I know you don't got bless you
motherfuckers.
I know you don't want to.
I know you don't want to and I respect
that and I think there's nothing wrong
with that.
I love those guys.
I don't want you shooting Debbie and I
don't think that because you eat meat.
I don't buy the argument that you should
have to shoot an animal.
I don't buy that.
I think we've allowed ourselves to have
somehow or another be removed from the
process of murdering,
slaughtering and butchering the animal
and we just enjoyed the meat,
which is kind of crazy if you really
think about it.
Fucking crazy.
So I just want to,
for my own personal edification,
I just want to go and experience it.
I want you to go,
why can we get a college shooting in
your back yard?
Well,
you know,
you could.
You know,
my,
my gardener got in trouble for killing a
goat as backyard.
What they do,
they got mad at them.
They were going to evict him from the
house and he's like,
I don't get it.
He's like,
he goes,
I,
I could cook right in my backyard
because why can't I kill a goat?
He was like,
this way,
you know,
it's not diseased.
It's safe.
It's like the safest thing to him.
I was like,
so normal.
Yeah.
It was like,
well,
it is normal.
I mean,
why can't he kill it?
How come he can cook it?
How come he can.
He could it be outside with a side of
beef sawn off chunks and nobody would
say a word.
They would say,
wow,
that's a big piece of beef out there,
but if you actually killed the cow and
start sawing the beef,
he would get in big trouble.
And I understand it because you've got
to get rid of the crust and that's one
of those neighbor rather than,
oh yeah,
someone rabid person to spend.
We don't give a fuck.
He's the way he was talking about it.
It's like,
why this is silly,
like,
come on,
this is that.
I want to make sure my meat is good.
You know,
animals,
not disease.
When I was a kid in Miami,
my uncle would get the pigs,
bring them up,
freedom for a couple of weeks.
Now I'm going to fucking kill him while
we were there.
Horrible.
I stopped eating pork for awhile because
I saw that movie,
my brother's keeper.
Did you ever see that documentary about
these guys that were kind of slow and
one of them I think got accused of
murder or something like that.
But anyway,
I'm in the documentary.
They live on a farm,
I believe in upstate New York.
I forget.
And uh,
the guy went to kill one of the pigs and
he pulls out the shotgun and the pig
starts run and that pig knows what the
fuck is going down.
Pigs are smart.
They're smarter than dogs,
so in this pig sees that shotgun,
he just starts fucking running and
squealing and scrambling.
The guys chasing after him finally gets
the gun to his head and blows his brains
out,
but like while before it happens,
that pig is an utter sheer terror and I
thought about that.
I'm like,
man,
I don't think I want to experience that.
Like,
why am I eating pigs?
Pig Bacon.
I eat it all the time.
I gave up lot.
Listen while I was like,
cows are dumb.
Fuck them.
They're but really the
shit that you're supposed to eat,
I think is the smart shit.
I think you're supposed to eat fish.
Not Smart,
but difficult to catch fish and game.
You know,
there was a hard to catch like cows and
pigs and you're sitting there laying
around.
That's probably not the best for you.
I appreciate your argument and I know
what I eat a piece of meat that some
cows hanging upside down with the
fucking thing of his neck.
I don't see it.
I don't want to think about it,
but by me going hunting,
which I really couldn't do anyway,
it would just make my life.
I know what I'm saying.
I don't even like venison.
I don't like none of that shit.
I feel Scallopini of discern,
tally and makes it to me and he goes,
I can't even feel like a motherfucker
and I eat it and I make believe I don't
even know what the fuck.
I mean.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like eating pussy coked up and
drunk the I can and that's it guys.
I eat meat because of my necessities and
stuff.
Fish.
No chicken.
I eat and even though like I know that
Nancy,
they piss all over the fucking legs.
Chicken,
I won't go to Popeye's chicken,
but eat chicken.
Popeye's is delicious.
Spicy chicken with rice and beans.
Fucking Popeye's.
Take the skin off and see the foot.
You can see the end of the stations of
the total.
They cut the foot and half and see what
the fuck's in there.
You'll never eat popeye's again.
You understand me?
I got his opinions are purely those of
is true.
I know all about your meat and all that
shit experience podcast.
This is all joey's opinions.
I for 1:00
AM a huge fan of the Popeye's chicken.
I wish to avoid litigation.
All right.
What about utilizing your like Popeye's
chicken player Loco's new chicken,
Jalapeno Sandwich to that?
None of fluid that I'm telling you,
man.
Oh,
player loco,
Jalapeno chicken sandwich.
They just came out with the bread as
they did selling the bread that Mexicans
in the back,
they.
They soak that shit in something.
It's like a mcgriddle chicken sandwich.
It's so good talking to Mexicans.
I got to get Mexicans promises sweet
because I haven't counted something I've
never encountered in my life.
I moved here to North Hollywood,
the coolest neighborhood I've lived in
in California,
and we actually have a Mexican ice cream
man.
You don't know what life is too.
You have a Mexican ice cream and there's
no schedule.
Some days it shows up at 10,
so some days he got ice cream.
Last week he showed up at 1115 while I
was watching the UFC on a Saturday
night.
Like you hear the fuck and I wish I was
joking with you guys.
This motherfucker comes at 11:00
being being.
You go out there.
The best soft serve ice cream I've ever
had out here.
Better than dairy queen.
All that shit.
Tremendous.
He had shoes on their last week.
It was selling shoes.
He's got popcorn.
That's hilarious.
As long as you keep moving.
I guess he's got.
He doesn't the ice cream.
Soft serve.
He dips it.
Like the thing,
like dairy queen is here at Bell School.
Is it?
Is it a truck with a motor?
A fucking huge truck like Mr.
softy and these coastal.
Okay.
Oh,
so the ice cream man?
No Music?
No.
Nothing like I've seen the ice cream man
downtown.
They're just because they allow.
They allow.
But I got there and it just talks in
Spanish and everybody flocks out.
See those guys try.
This has a truck that has
a belt thing here that people just come
out.
The ice cream is fucking delicious.
Great idea.
The ice cream truck.
Is this one of the greatest ideas ever?
No,
it's not.
You only see them in poor neighborhoods.
Right?
Well,
see him in a nice neighborhood.
It's hard to trust those motherfucker.
Some do just selling use of shit on the
street out of his truck.
That's not good.
I grew up on Mr.
softy.
That shit was still.
What are the laws that there are certain
laws.
No.
Yeah,
you have to have a license.
You can't just do that.
You have to have some sort of a merchant
slice.
You got to have a kitchen really hard
because trucks in rich neighborhoods.
But we really don't.
Do people want to buy it?
Man.
Rich neighborhoods,
you know,
you can't be going through Beverly Hills
and an ice cream truck probably trying
to rob,
you know what it is.
You know,
the main thing is they know in the rich
neighborhoods,
the kids just can't come out.
They can't get to end the day,
but the kids are out in the fucking
streets.
Three and four.
But like the kids are like fucking stray
dogs for neighborhoods.
Right.
And what I would go when I was little,
my grandfather,
when I was living with my grandfather in
Newark,
uh,
they would be playing stick ball in the
middle of the street.
You would have to stop and whatever.
They'd be playing soccer in the middle
of the street.
They'd be playing like,
right.
There's a mostly Puerto Puerto Ricans
and Dominicans and stuff in New York.
And you would literally have to stop
your car,
wait,
in order to get through to where you
wanted to go.
Tell them in the street cars coming.
Everybody would stop the game for a
second.
We did that car would drive by.
They'd restart the game.
Epic Got Damn Day playing football in
the street with cars.
That was the story of my life.
A bunch of poor fucking Mexican.
No one had a dad.
All 90 percent of all the kids were
like,
fucking the little rascals dude on my
fucking block.
It was,
it was a couple guys that were like 10
and 11.
Once my Stepdad left that I was gone,
I was on the streets.
I couldn't control me and my brother
Stepdad could.
But my,
once I was 10,
we were on the fucking streets and it
was like two,
three dudes that 10,
my brother,
14 and 15,
and then we had some 18,
19 year old and some 20 and we're all
mixed in plant foot.
Paul organizing,
she,
we're always on the street playing
basketball game with a bunch of Mexicans
and we're all in the rock.
And Eric was in the rush.
No one had a dad.
Everyone's dad was gone except for
loreal.
But fuck man,
there was a plan.
I did it with ice cream truck.
Oh,
ask them.
That was part of my life playing
football on the fucking street and asked
them truck coming by.
That was,
that was.
That was Irish Italian neighborhood.
And we played fucking everything on the
street,
stick ball football.
And then when their leaves came down,
that's where you play two hand touch and
the bricks.
We put the bricks in the middle of the
street and leaves on top of it.
And some dickheads driving with his car.
Oh my God.
The fucking animals.
When I lived in Jamaica plain,
when we first moved to Boston,
we moved to a better neighborhood,
moved to this place to make a plane,
and it was one of those streets where
you would live on the street.
There was like,
you know,
maybe 15,
20 kids that would live on the street
and they would be hanging out in the
middle of the street all night.
It was like 3:00
in the morning and you'd be like
watching TV.
They'd be like 10 feet in front of your
window,
screaming at each other,
yelling,
drinking beer,
throwing shit.
Oh,
summer nights,
nobody.
Nobody went to bed.
It was a blizzard.
When there was a blizzard.
Everybody was out in the street fucking
riding a,
taking sleds,
taking sled rides down,
live down the hill.
It was crazy.
My mom couldn't control us.
Gone every week we had a thing called
bombing.
Whenever we'd get together late at
night,
we'd get him Cammo a climb,
lemon trees filled backpacks with lemons
and then we climb another trees and we'd
be all camouflaged and a tree and when
the cars are coming by fucking told
lemons.
Adam and then they would stop.
Dude would come out,
he'd hiding in the fucking trees,
man,
and they would never find us.
We were all camouflaged.
We love camouflage,
but we would practice jumping fences and
escape routes.
We knew everybody's backyard and
everyone's fence.
We would practice,
so if any we got chased to the cops
would even come by a cop chases,
but they couldn't catch us.
What gone in the backyard.
So the fences we were going through know
I had this conversation with Brian Cowen
yesterday.
I'm going to have it again with you guys
too because we're all the same and the
three of us that we were kind of left to
our own devices,
you know?
Do you think that that's.
I think every interesting person that I
know,
almost all of them were not raised by
the parents.
They're all like raised like wild dogs.
They all like figured out their way
through the world.
Like they made a good relationship with
their mother,
but they don't really see her that
often.
She didn't really teach them things.
They kind of figured things out on their
own.
I for sure did.
Man,
I was leaving my brother on the streets.
My mom just had to work all the time.
She works.
If you have like,
if you had like a really cool dad who
was like a Christian who was like a real
Republican but Super Nice Guy,
you could've.
You could have thought like that.
If your dad raised you like that and
brought you along like that.
Who knows?
You could have.
I don't know.
Do you think that would have been
different?
My mind programmed,
right?
Your brain gets programmed by the people
that are around you and especially,
you know,
your influences and your teachers and
your father.
Of course it's going to be the biggest
teacher in your life if you find that
was a really nice guy and a sweet guy
and a fun guy in a,
a loving father and a Christian and and
like,
you know,
Really Gung Ho raw rob Republican.
You know,
the United States would never do a bad
thing to us.
You,
you could be sucked into that way of
thinking,
don't you think?
No.
You don't think so?
You don't think so because you're,
you and you grew up wild.
You grew up,
your parents died young.
You were,
you were really on your own and in a lot
of ways when you were taken in by
people's,
uh,
people's generosity,
like your,
your had a mom to a 14,
14.
That's very young thing.
My mom was pro American dog right here.
She was,
had a bookmaker and back.
It was involved with heroin.
Right.
But I'm saying to you,
it's very difficult to look at the world
like this is how you developed.
It's very difficult to step back and
say,
okay,
how much of who I am is my environment.
I'll tell you what,
when I a kid,
I didn't buy
into the boy scouts.
I didn't buy into none of that shit.
I never bought into clubs I never bought
into.
Now that she.
You grew up very streetwise.
You've got some stories about your
stepfather,
but under the age of 10,
I wanted to be a white kid in American
kid.
I came here from another country.
I grew up on Dick Van Dyke.
She just feel like insecure this day.
I'm insecure about being Cuban.
No,
I'm not about being Cuban,
but my big thing was to be an American.
My mother came to get funding to be an
American.
He wants to be everybody else's.
Why you want to be black,
black kids?
No,
no,
no.
When I came to this country,
my mom stressed that.
We came here for you to be an American
time on a bus.
Some kids are talking in Spanish and
they want to beat the teacher up because
the guy threw him off the fucking bus
and made them walk on and I walked into
the house and I told my mom,
my mom's like,
I don't know what you're upset about.
This is America.
You came here to do this.
My mom raised me to be an American and I
seen some of the Shit I bought into.
I'm hearing a song in the background
right now.
We're going to be some of the Shit I
didn't buy into.
Just the way that I never bought into a
lot of that shit.
I'm allowed to vote now.
I haven't had a felony in 15 years.
You can vote now.
I can vote now,
but I don't want it.
That's what happens.
It's a 50 year tenure,
but I don't want to vote because what
will my choices last year,
the old guy in Obama,
all three of them were bad choices.
Tell it.
I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
So part of me is in the other part of me
isn't what was tell what happened with
the dense.
You have someone hostage.
Can you talk 87?
I was a 27 years old,
whatever.
I was working in boulder.
I was going to school at night and I was
snorting coke with three hands and I
fucking got involved with some kid and
he was going to rob his roommate and
ended up robbing them.
Both of them.
The guy that I had an apartment was
gonna rob me what a tangled web we weave
when we tangled to deceive.
Just so happens that the guy got caught.
Like I told,
I told him I didn't want nothing to do
with it.
Even though I had the coke with me.
I sent the note to ask them,
but the other guy that got to try to rob
me,
he ended up getting pulled over with the
guy we kidnapped in the trunk of his car
all fucking bundled up and shit.
So I got arrested for the kidnapping,
kidnapping to and everything.
But you know what?
I fucked up.
It wasn't because I fucked up.
It wasn't because America,
listen bro.
I tend to seven.
I got a ticket this morning for $200,
ten cents to seven this morning while I
was sleeping I was going to tie cheer at
seven,
so I had to drive there.
So my wife said if you have to go to Tai
Cheer at seven,
you might as well drop me off at the
train station.
I usually walk every morning to a train
station,
but I drove her.
There was a lunch truck there I couldn't
pull over,
so I pulled by where she crosses the
street.
When I made the right one,
I made the left.
There was a cop.
He goes,
Bro,
the bus drivers complain.
He goes,
it's a thousand dollar ticket.
I have to give you a $200 ticket for
parking instead.
Is that okay?
And I took the ticket and I was not
angry with him.
I went to Tai Chee.
I did my thing.
I didn't mention that he did his job.
This is America.
He took his fucking job.
You fall uncertainty.
A lot of people got off at this guy for
pulling me over.
He did his fucking job.
You know what?
I kidnapped that guy.
I kidnap them.
I did that.
I got four years and I got all fucking
easy.
They should have thrown me in there for
10 fucking years,
but people don't really have time to
actually do 18 months.
Sixteen months.
That's a long for the cost.
Me Two years of my life.
You don't know what your life.
I'll press it.
Horrible.
No,
it was standing on my head,
but people that I could do that timely
time,
bro.
And you do time guys like you'd only.
It's just another day in paradise.
They're going to take us to a place
where we get the bullshit about Jujitsu
instead of two hours a day,
eight hours a day.
You follow me and you eat and whatever
your freedom gets lost,
which sucks,
but it's the people at home.
It's not you or whatever.
We.
I can do whatever the fuck I get.
My jeans are from Cuba.
Motherfuckers.
Tell me about.
I smoked the weed,
Castro smoke before we went to the
mountains to take over.
You understand me now?
What was a typical day in prison like
for you?
Like at that six month year in there?
Six months.
What's a typical day?
Living like a doctor who liked him,
Bro.
You gotta remember I went to prison for
four years.
I got sentenced,
but guess what?
I became.
I became a standup comic.
I learned how to do stand up on Thursday
nights.
They used to have movie night.
I didn't even know that dog.
They used to have movie night on
Thursday night,
so the projector would always fucked up
like stream.
It would always fucked up.
Joe.
We talk into the microphone.
It would always fucked up,
so on Thursdays the people just
jokingly,
I would always go,
what the fuck is wrong with the project?
And everybody will say Cuba,
get up there and talk.
So I would go up down negative result
you your people and like 100 more black.
So they go Cuba,
go up there and talk and that would make
fun of the black guys.
Like what would it be?
What would you say?
You know,
we make fun of the kitchen.
The kitchen is just the beginning of the
beginning.
We used to make for the ice to other
movies,
roles.
I fucking,
the first day in prison they made me a
baker.
You know,
you don't,
you don't tell people what you want.
It's like Cuba,
like yeah,
on the outside that was a mechanic
really.
Well in here you're a baker.
Here's a book,
learn how to make bagels maybe.
And almost blew up the kitchen,
right?
These motherfuckers so that the.
They fired me as a baker and they made
me a fucking dishwasher and wash and
they're stuck for real clothes and
whatever.
They had shitty meals.
The guys that I knew when they were
going through the line,
I would yell,
don't do.
So I would go,
don't do it.
How often were the meals?
Three times a week,
but it didn't matter because at lunch
time I was allowed to go to the store
for 15 minutes.
I worked it out where I had to drive to
take garbage out,
so I would go to the store for 15
minutes.
Not only that,
I would call it my own at the Chinese
restaurant,
so it would be ready by the time I got
there,
so I would go back to the prison with
Chinese food and groceries.
That's how strong I was in there.
Plus they were doing steroids and
selling drugs in prison waves like a
motherfucker,
so I always in the stock room clerks,
so they had to pay me rent so high
because they never stopped.
You start,
but you got to give me $3.
You got to give you some cigarettes.
Cigarettes.
I had pills and they have.
They just belong to other people,
but you put them on the pallets.
So I would give them a key,
whatever they needed to go take shit
out.
So they knew where the connection.
I was the.
I was to know I was the holdup.
Plus they get the steroids and so he had
to put it up their ass or whatever.
I don't know.
I never asked him.
Imagine shooting a steroid in the
smuggling in again going to get.
Then they put it.
Where that contact visits should do is
you take your fucking kid and you fill
his pockets with the [inaudible] and why
you're making out with your husband.
You said you want to see the kid and you
pass the kit to the husband and he takes
the drugs out that it gives your back.
That's how Henry Hill did it.
That's how they do it.
Same Shit.
It's no.
You can grow.
There's more drugs on the inside.
That was.
It wasn't the outside and to boot.
This was a minimum security camp.
We had contact visits.
When you have a contact visit,
there's parties every night.
These motherfuckers.
That's the first time I didn't know.
I was like,
the second time I did it was it couldn't
do a needle,
so the Mexicans took a Mexican thing.
A heroin melted it.
I'd put like a funnel in mind.
Those made out of paper and they dripped
to them my nose and I got mad like
candle wick burn out of my house.
What the fuck is this?
They're like,
that's heroin,
man.
Be Cool.
I was like this for like a day and the
white dudes,
Mike was a gimmie speed and they will
play basketball all fucking night.
I'll be out there,
be out there with them half an hour.
Every week was a new adventure.
Every drug was out there.
Fucking minimum security prison where
everyone's partying and greatest time
ever to take a public.
When you get,
when you,
when you get released.
It's like funeral,
which was even talking to Mike.
People keep complaining about.
I was,
I was.
When?
When I go to the halfway house I was
even better because I started loaning
money after the index.
As a loan.
Shark fix?
Yeah,
because they want to go out.
But if your rent's not paid on Thursday
and I allow for the weekend so the rent
will be $65,
so I give him 65 and 92.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I'm going to give you $65,
we got to give me 92 tomorrow and I had
10 guys on that role,
but I was a fucking machine in that scam
I had at the camp.
The biggest scam I had was with,
there was an old Italian dude,
Brooklyn.
He was like a half a mobster and he had
pool parties and he would only do one
card a week.
You would make like 30 bucks and I went
up to him.
I go,
Bro,
you have a problem with these cards?
I go,
you've given them two white guys,
you're not getting.
The black population is not getting the
fucking spics.
And he goes,
I don't know.
They won't talk to me.
I said,
give me the fucking card.
We're going to go partners.
He went from selling one card.
Every Monday they're doing 10 with me
because I had brothers,
I had the guns,
I had the Puerto Rican side,
the white and everybody and it was
amazing.
That's why I really learned that I could
really fucking do this.
So on Thursday nights they would say,
Cuba,
fuck the movie.
Just go up there and talk about the
kitchen and they all the with y'all
don't do it was fucking hysterical and I
was just talking about it.
And then I had this one crazy black guy
was [inaudible].
His name was spencer.
I'm from New Orleans and he was crazy
and he called me.
He told me that he was in there for
eight years for involuntary manslaughter
and he was my mentor.
That was my dog Jack.
He was fucking nuts and he would tell me
like one day some guy now them $2 and he
comes into the kitchen.
He goes,
did you see that guy?
And I go,
no,
I think he's packing and leaving this
motherfucker went and got a knife.
He got them at the gate as the guy was
getting out of Jay's like,
motherfucker,
you better get my $2.
I was blown away by this guy was old and
his parents and family had money there.
That's like the best attorney from Bro.
This guy killed somebody with his hands
and he got eight years with a black guy
and,
and uh,
and La Downtown la because I was in the
federal place.
He beat him with his fucking hands and
got eight years for voluntary
manslaughter.
He had like $50,000
attorney's this guy,
but he had a knife.
He got a gold tooth in his mouth.
He was one of those brothers and shit
that his eyes would go crazy.
Why do you think the gold to thing
really caught on in the black community?
Because it's fucking,
it's like a pubic hair in your mouth.
You know what I'm saying?
It's all about bringing,
you know what I mean?
Because that gets.
People look directly at your face.
So you want to,
you want to catch our attention.
That's why you got the necklace.
That's why you got to watch,
but nothing beats the next.
You know,
that's why they blamed the glasses out
tears and it's like,
yeah,
but that never caught on with the white
community.
That's where white people drew the line,
stopped.
They went up the,
the,
we can't join you on this one.
You know,
white people can't join you on this one.
Well Ma'am Ma'am Ma'am.
Where's it as a goof?
He's a character in real life.
Okay.
Listen,
in real life may have been walking
around with a grill on.
He does it like part of it is like to be
silly,
to be mayhem,
you know,
but it's not like he wants to be wearing
a nice style grill like,
like fucking little wayne or something.
Okay.
If,
if that is the case,
if mayhem does,
that's one out of like,
you know how many winners are there out
there?
Hey,
a big number.
It's a giant number and then I'll,
I'll tell you what Paul Wall,
right?
He's a white guy.
You know one thing about white guys that
wished there were black,
they are one,
they have all one thing in common.
They will deny that they would rather be
black than light.
They'll deny that shit no matter what.
Yeah,
you can that.
No,
I'm happy being myself.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just a hip hop culture,
hip hop culture thing.
You know,
it's where I grew up.
I grew up like this.
You know what I'm saying?
What I'm saying?
You know,
it's all above the game.
saw about the hip hop game.
They got an NBA Jersey pubic hairs.
You can't talk like that.
He got red pubic hair son.
They try extra hard,
you know,
white guys who want to be black,
they have to try extra hard.
Was crazy though.
But I with Eddie,
what I was telling you was data I want
in there.
Every Thursday I get on stage and then
one day this is fucked up Joe Rogan.
This is why I really dig it because one
day the guy in the library,
it was like a nerdy dude.
The guy that ran the library and I was
friends with them.
We did acid,
he was very into nostradamus and you
know,
he was intelligent but he had just,
he had some problem or something.
You went to prison and the funny thing
was that one day he came up to me in the
jail and a notebook was a big thing and
I was getting ready to get out and I
never even thought about it.
He came up to me and he goes,
hey bro,
I got shit notebook.
Like the notebook for you.
It was so when you get out you can write
some jokes.
He goes,
he goes,
every week you write jokes.
I never see the notebook.
And I looked at and I go,
I don't even write and this motherfucker
went nuts.
He goes,
you don't right,
and you go up there every we can do
that.
He goes,
when you get out of here,
it was like an angel.
It was like an angel.
I never seen the guy again.
I never heard from him again.
He just goes,
what I want you do,
you really need to write and get it
together because you have a gift.
Just pursue this and that guy never even
talked to me like he never used to talk
to me.
I just set it out of the blue,
came up to me one night.
He goes,
no,
the black guy,
white guy,
white,
nerdy guy.
That was like a really nerdy guy that
will always roll his own cigarettes or
some random guy came up,
got talent.
Do you think that if you didn't go to
prison,
if he didn't have that experience of
talking in front of those people that
you probably never would have done
standup over,
stand up something that was in the back
of your head anyway,
it was in the back of my head.
The prison really woke the animal up
because it before I had thought I bro,
if any.
Because you had to be funny before
prison heard the niggas crazy by Richard
Pryor.
You had to think of.
He pushed it so hard on that before
prison for the pilot,
I thought I was always good at.
I'm at the Deli.
I was always telling stories.
It was always good with that shit and
then the thing that really got me was
when you go to prison and do a
diagnostic on you and I like to get an
attorney now that really,
that's the only thing that irks me about
my life.
Like a lot of times people say,
Oh,
I slept with this guy with me is I
always wanted to know what's on that
paperwork because it was an intense
psychological evaluation.
It just wasn't a guy with a piece of
paper saying,
what do you think when you see a star?
Like they put shit in my head,
electrodes and all this shit.
It was three days of mental testing and
it was eating me alive and I wanted to
know.
I kept asking the counselor who was from
Mississippi,
he hated black people.
He hated specs.
He told me to my face.
My counselor told me.
He goes,
I hate.
I hate or you fuckers specs and I mean
that's how the counselor.
And he said to me,
he goes,
I go pro.
His name was Mr Blue.
I go,
what are you going to fucking tell me?
What's on there and one day he's like,
you really want me to tell him what time
he had bugged fucker.
That's what he would call me to my face.
Bug fucker.
He goes,
I'll tell you what,
hit Mr.
Buck fucker.
It said that if you really wanted
something and I had it that you would
take it from me.
He goes,
no,
you do what the fuck you want with that,
and they threw me out of his office and
I felt like a thief for three days.
That's what I read or that.
But what he was trying to tell me was
that anything I wanted in my life,
that's what it said,
that I could do anything you want.
You could do do it.
That's what he was saying.
That's what he was trying to beat around
and calling your bug fucker.
No,
by saying what he said,
lady came up to me.
He goes,
hey,
did you understand where I was going
with that?
He goes,
you're a smart guy.
You're not one of these guys.
Use to experience.
Tell us about your first standup Gig.
Do you remember it?
Yeah.
I remember.
What made you go up that night?
Do you consider the ones in prison there
first standup gangs?
I'm talking about birds and fish or at a
club.
Like your first time you went up like a,
but I'm.
It's.
I'm thinking that if you did it,
how many times did you do in a prison
you really were doing tonight?
I was doing every Thursday for sure.
If that's not a bunch of times you had
material.
Did you have material planned out?
Did you have stuff that you repeated
what you imagined?
Repeat new jokes in front of those young
shit and all those crazy Mexicans.
That's the first time I really knew
about the whole heritage.
They would sneak in.
Fucking Green Chili Burrito was
tremendous.
Really had the best tattoo artists.
Was it the Mexican Mexicans?
Mexicans always have wild jail tattooed
generations of Mexicans.
At one time I was in jail with the
grandfather,
the ils,
the father and the son.
Whoa,
that's really neat.
You start seeing that thing,
you know had been a movie right now.
This is fucking crazy and I always
wanted to shoot somebody and be a
criminal.
I didn't,
you know,
I always thought about that my life
deserve more than to spend it in here.
That's what prison did for me,
Bro.
If people come up to me and go,
how bad was prison?
Prison is how bad you make it for me.
For me,
it opened my eyes.
I became a standup comedy.
It just gave me that opportunity to see
by the way,
you see the show,
but that dude that robbed millions.
What's that guy's name?
Two years ago,
Guy.
They want to wave the Pudsey schemes.
You get a chance.
Watch that on fucking MSNBC show on Ms.
Bernie Madoff,
North Carolina.
Now.
He went right in and teamed up with the
fucking mob.
He paid people and he don't give a fuck
that guy about people.
Well,
you talked into people have to tell you
that you were finding that you should go
on stage.
Do people tell you that you should do
that?
Yeah.
Tell us about the first time on stage.
I would consider the first time he was
on stage.
The first time outside of prison.
The first time I was my first time on
stage was an open mic night,
but before I went to the open mic night,
it was locker room.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I understand that and if your first your
first night efficiently as a comedian is
an interesting one.
It's interiors,
but I'm so curious about yours.
The truth is,
the truth of the matter is now you get
down with it and remember it,
but come on dog.
About a month ago,
I got a call from a friend of mine and
we were talking that I hadn't talked to
her.
I hooked up with them on facebook and he
said something to me.
He goes,
Bro,
I knew on that bus ride home that you
always going to be an entertainer.
I asked him,
I go,
what are you talking about?
He goes,
do you remember if the freshman
basketball you would get on the bus and
fucking go off every night?
He goes,
it got to the point where the bus
drivers
wouldn't pick you up anymore because we
used to go on and do the theme from the
couple that had done it and then that
would go into a fucking 20 minutes,
get all the way we got to the say and I
even wrote a blog about it that after he
told me that,
like I called a bunch of people in those
days and I to go pro.
What do we do on the bus?
No,
like you don't remember.
We used to take over [inaudible] buses,
the number one bus,
90th street at 38th street.
We ran it and you were the fucking host
and MC.
And I'm like,
wow.
And I started thinking.
I'm like,
that's right.
So if I really go to that,
that was freshman year basketball.
Wow.
I used to like the buses up every time
and they would fucking pick.
I remember that like being out there for
two different bus drivers and they would
pick you up because you guys are too
fucking loud.
Wow,
that's hilarious.
But then in school,
you know,
no one ever considers that maybe this
guy should be a standup comedian.
They just go,
we got to silence him.
We've got to stop this.
We've got to teach some discipline to
you.
The lack of discipline is really what
makes someone a comic though I wasn't a
standup at all,
like in that sense,
like growing up.
But I was always every year,
depending on the teacher I had because
junior high and high school,
you have like seven teachers.
I was always the dude,
don't start shit.
Play pranks and always,
unless the teacher was Mr Endres you
never did shit.
He just fucking.
He was a bad motherfucker.
You know what you want to act up.
You want to.
Do you want to talk?
We talked about this before on the
podcast.
It was Mr Sanders,
Mr Sanders.
10th grade.
Uh,
I think geology.
I don't remember.
There's no way to tell.
You know,
the funny thing about someone becoming a
comic is there's no one who could have
pulled you aside and said what you
really need to do is become a comic.
It's like you almost have to experience
all this resistance to your personality,
to regular life.
Then that forces you into being a comic.
It's like someone can't just come up to
you and go,
this is what you really need to do.
You didn't really need to be a comic.
Like you need to go through all the
bullshit in life to experience that
before someone comes along and tells
you.
How old were you when you first got on
stage?
Thirty,
30,
29.
I was 20.
I was 21.
It would have been better for I 30
because when I was 21 I didn't have shit
to say.
I have no opinions about anything.
Kenneth,
my,
your comedians stand up comedians.
There's a lot of guys.
They can be fun and it'll be funny if
that's what they.
My problem was when I was 21,
my whole life from 15 to 21 was all just
taekwondo tournament and kickbox and
that's all I did.
That was 24 hours a day.
That was all I thought about.
I didn't really consider the world.
I didn't.
I didn't want to be a loser and I wanted
to be really good at talking window and
I wanted to win the nationals and I
wanted to compete in the Olympics.
I had all these ideas up.
I didn't know about fucking politics.
I hadn't a clue as to what was going on
in the world.
I didn't even think about it for a
second.
Oh,
I thought about was this and getting
laid.
That's what I thought about.
So when I started going into comedy,
I literally had no opinions.
I know how to kick somebody.
I don't know how to kick somebody in the
head and I know I like pussy,
pussy jokes,
sex jokes for like the first year and a
half.
So I wrote this when I'm 21 years old.
What the fuck?
Kind of the opinion that I have.
That was interesting on anything.
If I told you anything about anything
other than sex or kicking somebody in
the head,
you would already know what I was going
to say way in advance.
I,
I didn't have enough life experience.
My life experience is very limited.
I hear that a lot,
that people to yell to say maybe 30
years.
The kind of comedy you do,
will you look at you,
look at you,
you stupid.
Fuck,
you know,
you do that kind of comedy.
We appoint some shit out.
Well,
you can't point some shit out at 21.
You're not seeing it was I going to
listen to you.
You're not going to listen to you unless
you're some super genius and even then
it's probably not going to be funny.
You know,
I just,
uh,
I wrestled with it for awhile.
I was a roofer after I got locked up.
I roof for one week,
fucking two or three years I was,
I went to school and then I was sick and
tired of people telling me try it.
I was getting breakfast one morning,
opened up a paper and there was a be a
standup comedian class for $33 and I
took it.
I was not funny at all.
I was not a funny person.
I wasn't funny until I started doing
taekwondo and we would fight and compete
in tournaments and everybody be nervous.
You'd be nervous even in the locker room
when you're about to go work out because
somebody might just get kicked in the
face and knocked out.
It happened all the time.
Guys got knocked out in class all the
time.
They get kicked in the face and you'd
get fucking terrified and so I was
always cracking jokes to break the
tension.
I was always the guy who's doing
impressions of other people on the team.
That was the first time that I became
funny because the other than that,
I just.
I didn't think I was funny like loved
comedy though,
man.
God Damn.
I just thought the idea of it was so
crazy.
The first time I saw Richard Pryor live
in the sunset strip,
I couldn't fucking believe this guy was
just talking.
He's on stage just talking.
It was one of the most profound moments
of my young life.
I was like 13,
I think I was in the audience.
I was just looking around and people
were falling out of their chairs
laughing and I was holding my stomach.
Remember my stomach was hurting because
I was laughing so hard and I was
thinking,
how crazy is that?
This guy's just talking.
He's just talking and what he's saying
is way funnier than any movie I've ever
seen.
I was thinking of stripes at the time
because stripes was this amazing movie,
you know,
Bill Murray,
the funniest guy ever and Chevy Chase
and then together in this movie and it's
incredible.
This was way funnier and this is just a
guy talking.
He was just to delirious is what got me
and I was like 13,
12 or 13 when that came out and me and
my brother watched it at his
girlfriend's house,
who's who lived with her mom and we were
watching it with my brother's
girlfriend.
We were fucking buying because they are
the only ones that had like it was a VCR
or something.
No one had vcs we were dying to.
Then the mom came home and we stop
laughing and she was standing right
there.
We did.
We just froze.
We're like,
oh shit,
we're going to get busted.
Destruction.
Yes.
She stood there.
Her fucking Eddie Murphy go off and she
didn't say shit.
She doesn't.
She didn't say hi or nothing.
She would fuck.
We didn't laugh at all.
She went upstairs,
Pam,
and then when that was the funniest shit
ever,
ever delirious was at the time and he
was.
He took it to a whole new level of
destruction.
That terrible.
Now that it's not good.
Funny.
Is it funny?
When I was a kid,
man,
that was the best shit.
As the greatest comedy does not hold up,
man.
It is not.
A lot of.
It does not hold up and most old standup
comedian ever wants to like some old bob
hope.
Shit.
It'll make you want to jump out the
fucking window.
Lenny Bruce.
What's out of this fucking hole?
I still got so much shit that was
timeless.
Timeless is early.
Kinison will always be lenny.
Bruce has a few timeless moments.
He's got this.
He goes,
homosexual.
You wanna make homosexuals illegal.
So dig this.
This is what they do.
They take a guy who's gay and they put
him in prison with a bunch of guys who
want to have sex with him.
I mean,
come on man,
he knocked that shit out of the park in
like 1950.
But you know what,
that's funny.
That's funny.
That would stand up now when you go dig
this man.
Take this bad.
So catch this.
But towards the end he went crazy.
Towards the end,
he would just go on stage with his legal
papers and read from his legal
documents.
He was out of his mind.
He was fucking nuts riding.
That's another,
that's another classic.
Lenny Bruce.
There's not that many.
Oh,
uh,
yeah.
He had one about a.
He goes out Catholics manner.
I don't think they get it,
you know,
it's like,
uh,
you know,
Jesus comes back,
he wants to see a cross.
It's like a guy walking around with an
electric chair around his neck.
So let me ask you something.
Let me boost it.
That first.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Wow.
Yeah.
That was lenny Bruce's chuck.
Wow.
That's pretty deep.
What I seen,
what I heard,
bicentennial Nigga and I said,
Richard Pryor,
son from that
I remember so many classic,
we'd have to look at it because he has
one from.
You'd have to see the best one from
whatever it is.
Hey Man.
Say Nigga you went to Cape.
Why your window?
What's your name?
Boy Dracula.
What kind of name is that for a Nigga
from Transylvania.
I know where this Nigga.
You ain't the smartest motherfucker in
the world,
you know,
but you're the ugliest.
Oh yes.
You're ugly motherfucker.
And what's that then on the back of your
neck.
You are filthy little motherfucker too.
You better go home before the sun come
up.
I ain't lying.
See you're asking where you live.
Look at arrested.
You want to suck but suck some black
niggas.
You use some kind of freak boy.
Ugly Freak.
Oh crap.
That was my heart was my heart guys.
I listened to that.
He had bone in there.
All Bonnie's restaurant.
Give me another,
another beautiful one more soundbite.
Our gang mud bone goes to Hollywood.
Chinese restaurant.
Where he told I knew Jesus.
I met that Nigga at the railroad depot.
I told them,
don't you go down there messing with
them Jews without no money.
Fire was the gene was great,
but bison today with it,
he goes to the baptism in the face like
a lion and a body like a separate.
I don't know about you but don't want to
see.
No,
motherfucker got
it looks like that.
You're fine man.
When I was a kid,
when I was in high school,
my me and my girlfriend Bethany,
we used to come home from high school
and I had a cassette player when
listening to Richard Pryor cassettes and
just giggle because we knew it shouldn't
be listening to this.
Just giggle and laugh it dude.
There was this guy that I worked at ups.
We work next to each other on and and on
an assembly line when we're sorting
boxes it's just we're just fucking a
conveyor belt with boxes and we'll just
of dude,
dude,
that's a shift from 2:30
to 7:30.
That was my life was waking up at 1:30
1:32.
I kept that job today.
They would have paid job for that.
Was that just got bought out by buddy?
Did that.
Can you imagine you had the same job
since high school?
Oh my God.
Would have to go on a level of 15 and
worked till three as a senior in Judea,
but guess what?
When ups went public,
they paid that motherfucker $3,000,000
million.
They went public because he had 30 years
of stocks.
They were just giving away stops,
like just give this guy.
He's a part time,
but it was a nightmare.
Man.
I must felt that so much.
When he stopped talking to his brother
and everything,
just stopped talking to his brother.
The brother called was like,
Bro,
where they have business investment
opportunities.
We'll talk people.
Always a business investment.
I was telling him,
you know,
there was this guy lost his black guy
that I worked next to.
We fought a lot,
man.
We've had box wars and shit.
It's a long story man.
He was pissed off.
The conveyor belt was busier than mine
and I was the new guy.
He was fucking pissed,
but anyways,
he would always have a ghetto box and he
fucking played.
Andrew is a black guy named Phil
Collins,
a black guy named Phil calls.
He was always angry that he got the belt
boxes were coming.
I go through a boxes at me and shit and
I felt like,
God damn it,
this sucks.
I got to quit.
But anyways,
he would always play Andrew dice clay
and ghetto box.
He knew Andrew dice clay every yet at
that point it was like 1990.
Andrew dice clay had a couple of.
He had a few cds at that point.
He knew everything.
He would put a different one the day the
laughter died.
Oh,
he was just going back and forth and it
was,
you know,
um,
that's my story about and a comedy.
I got to tell Joe while we're on the
subject and it's very interesting.
I used to always tell you about ups.
People always telling me how they used
to ship ship.
I'll use pdfs and I take them aside and
go,
don't ship on ups because I.
my buddy's ran the,
the paramus one and they have a little
gate where they have rolexes and
diamonds because they ship all the
world's diamonds on ups.
A lot of people don't know that and they
have a gate,
so when that bell goes off,
that means security gate go opens and
they would have these conveyor belts and
these guys would have to switch it up.
Yep.
Well my buddies would take shit and
throw it under the conveyor belt and it
would get stuck in rip open.
The dude I got.
I got shit to show up with Rolex
presidential bitches and they were
selling them for 10 k cash other than
three a week,
making 8:50
of our ups selling three.
President may not know there was so many
getting stolen because they were
uninsurance anyway for surveillance
cameras,
cameras rip open because the boxes will
just want to take the box and thrown on
the floor.
They have tracking numbers and shit.
They know where it stopped.
They would take the box and throw it and
the conveyor belt so the belt would
break it open and then it would say the
watch got that,
but just some pieces go get it.
The watch was in there fucking pocket
with the warranty and everything.
So a $20,000
watch that you would.
They would sell three a week.
These kids,
each of them look yanking 90 grand a
week out of that,
plus diamonds plus anything else that
came out of fuck ups,
those stocks,
the good old days was the worst job
ever.
You don't move.
You don't stop moving.
It was so bad that the position I had,
I thought it was a promotion,
like I thought it was moving up in ups
and the way you get into ups.
It's hard because I was working as a
temp at the United States post office
and that she was only six months a year,
something like that and it was coming to
and so I had to get another job,
so I had people that worked at ups.
They go,
dude,
try ups.
It's going to be really hard to get in
though.
They hire three out of 30 people that
they come in,
they bring 30 people in this higher
three and I'm like,
dude,
it's,
they're looking for warriors.
Dude,
it's really hard.
It's really hard to 30 to 7:30
and they work you for hours,
like a fucking dog.
Eight bucks an hour and minimum wage
back then was 3:35.
So it was like,
I want that fucking money,
you know?
So I went in there and just bullshitted
my way through and I went to the fucking
interview and,
and they go,
why do you think you're good for this
job?
I love working in the middle of it
graveyard shift.
I'm always up.
I have so much energy.
I just want to so much energy at that
time.
I'd love hard work.
I don't want to work retail and deal
with people I want to work in the back.
So basically what I did was like what
you would do to a chick.
You try to pretend that you're something
you're not.
Yes,
totally.
When did they?
They,
they,
they called the three finalists and it
was one of them was me and I'm like,
fuck yeah.
I came in,
I knew I just bullshitted my way
through.
You guys had finalists and there was
three of them.
Three out of 30 people,
they fucking called Our Name.
We fucking come in and then they take
us.
They give us on,
give us a tour of ups isn't tremendous
warehouse did you say?
I really think that my career is here.
Yes.
All that shit.
I can see the quote retiring with ups.
So at first when you first come in,
this is 1:30,
you're unloading semis.
Their first job is you get in the semi
though to worse motherfuck there's all
these semis and go,
you're a part of the semi crew,
you're just putting fucking boxes on
conveyor belts and another conveyor
comes up and then the first guy sorts it
by zip code and he has a bunch of belts
behind him and he's going for.
So I'm in a fucking truck going flocked,
working hard going,
I got to get out of this fucking truck.
I need to be on the sword is all the
dust and here this is for the fucking
slaves.
Fuck this shit.
So finally they bumped up.
Now I'm a splitter and they time your
ass.
They timed.
They're like hiding in the conveyor
belt.
How many packages can you.
Oh to go dude.
You can't think you're like there's nine
belts behind you and you're like fucking
going crazy.
But I would know when they were watching
I would know.
I was like,
I'm like,
I'm like always looking around,
always looking on my,
Oh this motherfucker going to me.
I would miss sort everything.
I was just missed sorting shit.
They don't know who the fuck Miss Swartz
Shit.
And after we would have our meeting or
was a great day.
You guys did great.
Like the team leader.
Fucking Edgar Bravo again.
The record holder for the day.
The guy's on fire,
he's doing great.
I was the fucking dude.
I was the man and you really sucked.
That wasn't that good.
But I just can see them timing my ass.
And when it was time for the big
promotion,
way up the conveyor belt,
like the dude who sorts for the actual
trucks that are going out the conveyor
belt,
they go,
we go up the promotion,
goes to Edgar Bravo for his fantastic
work and it's fantastic times.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
what a whack system.
Definitely not know you're a horse horse
shit dude.
It just whack those hilarity.
They don't get ms dot because there's
conveyor belts that go for fucking
hundreds of yards and they've gone
through all this shit.
It's complex.
By the time when down the road and the
conveyor belt,
they see a missort goes to the
Minnesota,
Iowa and it comes all the way back.
They don't know who the fuck assorted.
They make mistakes all the time.
You don't know what the fuck's going on.
They're fucking idiots were.
Anyways,
I thought I got a promotion,
got a fifty cent raise,
and I'm sitting there back to back like
mere you're sorting for people behind
you and I'm sorting for people behind me
and it's me and Phil Collins and we're
going,
I'm the the reason the guy quit.
I didn't know he couldn't handle working
with Phil Collins because Phil Collins
is like,
just this being fucking black guy.
That was really cool before work started
with everyone to.
Well,
what about the jets?
Oh my God.
Did you see fucking boomer esiason?
He was on fire.
Everybody was really fucking cool and at
2:00
in the morning,
but once it starts,
you start fucking getting pissed and he
would get pissed that I did that.
I was getting help because I was new.
I was fucking out that the guys were
always helping me,
the managers,
but they weren't helping him,
so fuck man.
It was the worst job ever.
I ended up quitting.
They were begging me to come back
because to get a guy to get it takes
like two months to fucking have that
shit wired.
It takes a long time and until you get
it wired,
the fucking guys got to help you.
The manager's got to help you.
They don't want you to quit.
We just put an at fucking nine months in
with you.
You better not quit.
I would quit them were begging me to
come back.
I'm like,
I'm gone.
My back hurts.
I faked a back injury.
I just gave me the fuck outta here.
Well,
we're all happy he did that because then
we would have lost him,
Bro.
You.
I would've been able to look ups.
Only a blue belt.
You'll never gotten the Abu Dhabi fucked
up.
Thank God for Phil Collins.
If you're out there.
Thank you man.
Thank you.
Phil Collen.
How do you spell it?
Ran from H I l c o c o l l e dot.
I don't remember because it too.
Phil Collins is a drama.
Then there was a guitar player from
call
def leopard seal concrete.
If you're dealing with some fucking
novels here.
What I'm saying was the song of the
week.
I bought fucking can't play songs on
this laptop here for this film.
Why?
Listening to let us get it.
Who I never even seen coming out of the
woodwork,
but I heard a free bird.
Oh my God.
They fucking around though.
Where they had some fucking Gemini.
All them brothers.
Those sweet home Alabama.
To this day here when he says,
oh,
my mother fought jam.
That's an all time jam.
Fucked her rent money.
So once you got going on this weekend,
I got nothing man.
I was going to go to the south and I
don't know what happened.
There was comedy hose temporarily down
because he's got no liquor license.
Just chillax and I got to keep writing.
You guys are doing a Gig in Austin.
That's the 14th.
The 14th.
A Wednesday.
Next Wednesday.
Tuesday or Wednesday.
Tuesday night.
Joe Rogan.
Ultimate multiple times.
Just you and Jelly and Austin.
Beautiful.
Romy.
Do all my thing to next Wednesday.
Next Wednesday is your monthly show.
Who's doing it?
Who's done online with you?
I'll do that and let me know what's
cracking because again,
I'll do that.
That's really big.
It's been a lot of fun letter even
selling that place out,
right?
Yeah man.
We've been doing good fucking numbers.
So every month joey does a.
where can they find out about the show?
An improv?
Improv.com
seven.
One,
four,
eight,
two.
Oh,
700.
Where could they like?
Do you have when you're going to be
there?
Did.
If you go on the,
uh,
if you go on the schedule has me on
that.
Do you have your website updated?
No,
I have the beauty and the beast website
up.
You gotta update your website,
your website.
I mean you're,
you're always doing something.
You know,
I've got a lot of people that would like
to know where you're going to perform.
They know they need to get you a real
schedule.
I hit him up on twitter and if you don't
know Joey's twitter,
it's on the youth stream page.
You can see it there,
but about flavor flavor,
mad f l a v O r out.
A little bit about that.
Brian knows all about it.
I'm glad that you're finally at least
connected to the Internet and really
into this and you for.
You are right.
A lot of blogs for awhile.
I still write every Monday I put them
up.
Where do you put them up?
My space.
She's jealous on the Internet.
Still rocking my space because that's
where I started with that.
It's too hard to transfer moment.
Have copy and paste list.
The problem I have,
I have three different batches of
people.
My facebook has more family people like
real quick and they know,
but they don't know what I'm saying.
For the people.
My people on here,
you motherfuckers are the best.
I can talk about mass.
I can tell you about stabbing Puerto
Rican.
You guys are the best.
My space.
I go all right,
but there's nobody left.
It's like me and a couple people,
but I blog my space just because I
started on it and sometimes I get.
If I get a lot of hits real quick,
I put it on twitter or something because
it's kind of weird how my space just
fucking just hard.
I've never seen anything like,
yeah,
but if we got crushed,
I don't know about that.
We just keep moving.
I think facebook is a better product.
Better.
I like my mind space.
I don't even put.
I don't even bother advertising for
seminars at all,
you
know?
Yeah.
I don't.
I don't even touch my shows anymore on
my space.
Just keep it up for the music.
People want to hear my music
temporarily.
My music's up on mind space.
That's it,
but I don't.
Fuck.
I don't fuck with the Jujitsu part of
it.
Facebook is just so much smarter with
their updates and shit and go to your
timeline and see all this different shit
that's happening.
It's kind of interesting.
You know Bob's in a relationship with
Lisa.
Oh,
no shit.
Huh?
Click this girl.
Busy body instead.
Fucking looking through it.
Now.
The September 19th,
I'm in Rochester at Tenth Planet
Rochester with Chris Herzog was
September 18th.
September 18th is Rochester at the
Saturday is the viper room of the sunset
grill.
The Sun that strip out those dates.
Wrong man.
For some reason.
The 18th.
Saturday.
Yeah.
The 18th is Rochester or the 19th is the
viper room viper room.
If you want to get on the guest list,
Twista Bravo@sbcglobal.net.
I'll put you on the guest list.
If you're in La.
September 19th,
Sunday,
9:00
PM tenders is your band.
Yes.
September 18th,
Bro.
Eighteenth is a Saturday night.
Is Rochester.
Rochester Sunday is the viper room.
Yes.
Sunday night viper.
Monday is a holiday,
so come up.
Opening of the UFC gym on the 18th.
I'm going to Rosemead oh shit.
Columbus.
Columbus is September.
Twentieth is probably Columbus Day.
October 10th is a something else.
I guess also my new website's up.
All the techniques of freon that all the
shit that I put up on my website is all
free stuff that I charged for before up
until October first.
So a,
watch them all.
Tenth Planet Jj Dot Com.
Click techniques please.
Thank you.
So,
uh,
you chick fucking picked up for cocaine
this weekend in Vegas.
That dubby Paris Hilton or.
So what happened?
Her homeboy.
This is what I tell you.
Don't smoke in the car.
Cock sucking,
smoke smoke in the car.
This is a running joke that Joey Diaz.
We'll just hop into a fucking car in the
middle of a police parade.
It doesn't,
it doesn't mean shit.
He'll just start lighting that.
Where's the reef of cock?
Sucker.
What are we doing there?
We playing games.
They'll just start light and joints and
I,
I'm always thinking we're going to get
pulled over and we're going to get,
you know,
this is not good.
You're not supposed to smoke weed in the
car,
so we should have a rule.
You should never smoke weed in the car.
Don't smile while I'm driving too much.
Like an hour.
You're,
you're vulnerable,
you know?
Well,
not only that,
it's just stupid.
She was smoking,
the windows were open and the fucking
slope and there was a bike cop or
something and he drove right by them and
smell the weed,
the weed.
So he pulls him over and finds coconut
car,
this bitch ass to go to the bathroom,
goes to the bathroom for guests.
You know when you got pulled over,
the first thing you do is you take the
illegal substance,
putting your fucking snatch,
especially if you're abroad.
If you're a guy pulling your ball sack,
where did this happen?
Touched Vegas.
Ooh,
she in jail.
No,
no,
she got let out.
But grace was very upset.
Who is she to be let out of jail?
If it was you or I,
we would be in there right now.
That's taken of Dr Phil.
I bred some stuff.
Read tabloids that he's having trouble
with his wife.
Is that all bullshit?
Is that bullshit or is that real?
What do you think is a fuck that?
No,
I don't give a fuck like hundreds of
millions of dollars.
And I pitched him pitches not knowing
what I'm saying is I don't give a fuck
what anybody does in their own life with
their marriage.
I don't wish any harm in their marriage.
I hope everyone has had that
motherfucker.
Dr Phil.
I'm going to enjoy watching his life
fall apart.
Why?
He's a fucking idiot,
man.
I hate that guy.
Wow.
Strong word.
I hate that fucking guy.
He's a fucking backstabber to the,
to the,
um,
the male gender.
Come on.
That guy's the biggest fucking.
He's a writer.
He's hustling whatever.
Everyday I'm hustling.
It's gonna.
Be Funny.
Hustle.
It's going to be funny to catch him
busted with hookers and shit.
That's going to be fucking huddle.
Every guest.
It's going to be interesting.
What does happen to him?
He's going to have to be very careful
about his image.
If he does get divorced,
he could be total horseshit and he could
be getting along with his wife.
Great.
But if he gets divorced and he's out
there wilding,
he's out there,
Dayton,
because there's going to be bitches.
I want to set them up and try to get on
TMZ.
How about the Dr Ferraro sketch that was
on the man show.
There was a two parter.
I mean that shit on the Manchester.
It was a reality when a guy that was
posing as a Dr Phil was,
had a fake book signing and people up.
He was saying all kinds of crazy shit.
Yeah,
like,
like the girls were aligned.
They didn't even know it's him.
It looks like him.
But I probably didn't fool everybody.
But man,
it was a,
it was a total punk.
Like he would say,
like when he was signing in,
I got some coke back in the hotel room.
You down and curls.
But like yeah,
hit.
And then he was,
he was making moves on this one chick
and from under the table a girl came
out,
like he had been getting a blow job and
just walked away and he just kept
talking to him.
You want to party,
get your friends.
It's got like a telco and down at it
was.
It was so funny.
That's gets.
It was so much material.
It was the only comedy.
It was the only man show sketch that two
parts.
They did it again the next week.
There was so much material.
It was too funny.
If Stan up and I had a real show where
we could have really done what we wanted
to do,
it could have been very interesting.
There was two problems with doing that
mantra.
One was and I was doing fear factor at
the same time.
That was crazy day.
Easy days in the middle of all that man
show shit.
I'm training for Abu Dhabi.
I'm looking for.
The man showed depressed out of my mind.
It was the worst from day one inside.
I wanted to kill myself.
I'm like,
this fucking is not what I thought it
was going to be.
Started out what it was supposed to be,
was supposed to be.
We would be able to do whatever we
wanted.
The way they sold it to me was the
beginning.
Explain the beginning how they offered
you the show while you.
Here I was doing fear factor and they
were saying we want you to take over the
man show,
and I was like,
Woo Hoo Hoo.
In they as well,
we have a short list people.
Is there anybody that you would
want to do it with?
And I'm like,
there's only one guy doug stanhope.
I go,
that's the only way it would work.
he's the only guy that's like,
that fits right in there with me,
like my sensitivity,
my sensibility rather.
And so,
uh,
they said,
well,
you guys would be perfect.
You can do it.
I'm like,
but it would be too restrictive.
They're like,
no,
you don't understand.
A lawsuit would be good for us.
The Guy Actually said this to me.
He said if we got sued,
okay,
it would be great publicity.
It would be great.
Want to do we want to do nudity,
blur it out.
If you want to swear,
beep it out.
Essentially you could do anything that
you would talk about an real quick.
We already had like 10,
15 ideas for sketches even before that.
So this was like a perfect thing.
I remember you called me go,
dude,
the fuck comedy central wants me to take
over the man show.
How fucking crazy is that?
We were just.
We were thinking.
So anyway,
what happened was,
yeah,
totally it was.
It was very strange and they came up to
me and they basically just gave us a
story about what they're going to be
able to do for us.
We're going to have some show.
It's going to be completely wild.
You can do whatever you want,
but once we got in there,
it was a completely different story.
They had like really restricted ideas
about what the subject matter should be.
The guy who was the executive producer
wind up like kind of hijacking the show
and taking all the things on his
direction and this is the guy that me
and doug hired.
He had his own hire.
The head writer slash hated you.
You and him.
You remember that,
right?
Remember that?
The head writer,
I remember you going out to dinner
because Deborah,
before you signed,
you were like,
let me pick the head writer.
You said,
can I hire my guys?
I'm going to bring in my guy.
What was your guys' name?
The Bald Guy?
The comedian mcguire?
Yes.
You wanted to bring in Chris Mcguire and
Maddie Kirsch and me and they said,
no,
whatever you want to do,
man,
whatever it's going to have total power.
You have total power do.
And you're like,
damn.
And you're calling me.
He'll do.
They give them a total fucking power.
It's good.
Well,
I want to be able to hire the head
writer.
You went out and met with some guys and
you met with Janice.
Not Get too into this.
Um,
I,
I know what you're saying,
but I don't want to throw Tom Johnson
under the bus.
I think he's a talented guy.
He just did what he thought was the
right show and I wasn't there.
Well,
I wasn't there in the network.
Had real serious ideas about what they
wanted and you know,
they,
they were the ones running the show and
coming up with the money and they had
some real serious ideas about what they
thought was funny.
And one of them was they didn't want
joey on the show and I want joe to come
out at the beginning of the show naked
and introduce everybody.
He would come out with a microphone,
the handheld microphone.
Let's get this party started.
And Joe is dancing and everything.
It was probably one of the funniest
things we ever did.
And they fought to the point of tears.
This fucking chick who I like,
very nice person,
she's an executive.
She's telling me,
why is that funny?
I'm like,
how could it not be funny?
I go,
you're going to get Joey Diaz.
He's going to run out naked.
You pixelate his balls.
The crowd's going to go crazy.
It's going to put them in the perfect
mood.
I just don't see how this is funny.
I don't see others.
It's funny.
Tears are coming down her eyes.
I go,
we'll do two intros.
We'll do one without it and we'll do one
with it.
We do one without you go out there.
The fucking place goes ape shit.
They are falling down laughing.
It was hilarious.
The best intro ever.
And I got that on camera.
So then I go to her and I'm like,
you know,
raise my hands.
I've see told you like you got to.
I know what I is funny.
I'm capable of reproducing what I think
is funny.
You might not think it's funny on paper.
You might not think.
It's funny as I'm describing it to you,
but I know it's funny to me and if it's
funny to me it's going to be funny to
other people.
It just has to be the second it was that
went to college for four years.
Why?
The reason Chappelle quit because you've
got to buy it.
Turned out it was the reason why Adam
Carolla and Jimmy Jimmy Kimmel stopped
doing it.
It's because they,
they gave up ownership of the show so
that they could have creative control
they gave up on because they're tired of
these idiots and they gave up.
They were like,
look,
you guys can have the fucking show.
We just want to be responsible for what
gets done.
And they for sure didn't want to hire
me.
They said,
no,
no.
Once you signed,
they go.
Now this Eddie Bravo has no TV
experience,
why the fuck do we want him on the show?
And they're like,
no,
we're not gonna hire them with higher
Chris Mcguire and bought out.
But no,
the problem was they didn't understand
what I was trying to do.
I was trying to.
I was like,
look,
he's.
He says funny shit.
He comes up with some funny ideas.
He might not be like a writer in,
in as far as like,
he's not going to come up with a,
a properly formatted sketch,
you know,
without everything.
I mean he could eventually do that,
but for right now what he's good at,
he's good at looking at things,
funny,
smoking pot,
coming up with crazy ideas and you
could,
you know,
there's a tailor and having a.
They weren't hearing it.
You got to us it was,
he wanted it to be his show and I wasn't
there enough.
I was doing fear factor at least three
days a week.
So for three days they would be running
the show and Doug did not feel confident
enough to take over and he would send me
messages.
He would call me up and go,
dude,
is fucking hell here.
This is just driving me crazy.
It's just fucking stupid sketches
getting in and I can't get this done.
And,
and then the Janet Jackson Nipple thing
happened and then we were fucked because
then shit that we already had approved,
they yanked out,
they pulled shit out of episodes because
after that Janet Jackson Nipple fiasco,
people don't know who weren't in show
tilts.
A lot of people was nothing.
Some chick poser tit out in a video or
you know,
in a,
in a super bowl thing rather.
And it's like,
who cares?
It's kind of gross.
It was stupid,
you know,
they did something.
It's over,
you know,
but to the,
to,
to Hollywood that costs people money.
People worried about sponsors pulling
out,
people worried about losing commercial
money and they acted man.
They started chopping up sketches and
removing bits and everybody went on a
panic.
They were all sheep.
They just went on this panic.
Sheep run,
banging into walls,
tripping over themselves,
trying to stop comedy.
How about the sketch that we wrote that
they originally approved and they backed
out of.
We were going to do extreme sack
fighting.
It was funny because I never forget the
day that that all went down.
I,
between you,
me and all three of us and I didn't want
to fucking be there either.
It was the worst fucking thing.
I was around.
It was a bad energy,
right?
It was set up that energy.
No,
forget that.
I went.
They made me rehearse like Jack Offs
that they were.
And uh,
the guy,
Tom,
Janice came over and oh,
it's hysterical.
We love it.
Then the next day I go there and now
everybody's talking about it.
It was hysterical to see all these
fucking educated white people walking
around like they didn't know what the
fuck to do.
He's gonna take his balls
up and he's going to run.
They got killed and that's it.
So they all were arguing,
see direction.
We want to go in.
This is like a fucking whore.
It's not want a job.
Push this through with all his might do.
This is not a direction we want to go
in.
Hired me to do what I think is funny.
Tell me what to do.
Some crazy shit.
We're gonna do some crazy shit.
And then they wanted me to be a junkie,
a man junkie and take a piss and I'm
like crack.
And I was like,
this ain't gonna happen.
Yeah.
They're like,
we want them to know makeup and
everything.
When Joey came running out,
all bets were off,
so I had to shut up or at least that
day.
So we had to shoot two episodes that
We had to shoot two episodes and I was
going to run through both of them,
but even after the first one,
even after they seen the laughter,
they were like,
it's not going to happen.
But what got me was I'm not familiar
with this environment of a fucking
standup comic at the time.
I had done a couple things,
but I wasn't familiar with the whole
other side of this big Hollywood butches
lying.
So the guy who was telling me to my face
how funny I am,
I catch them when I get offstage.
Telling the comedy central people that
it was tasteless and he thought it was
terrible and he said,
tell Rogan how my balls aren't funny and
I must've dude and all of a sudden look
at him and I fucking was raging and as
I'm at the end of the show I'm side.
And what really happened was because I
don't give a fuck,
I was smoking a joint with the security
guard.
Got a joy run on the set,
you know,
I don't give a fuck and me and this.
The security goes like what you're
doing.
I go smoke it.
You.
Once we went into a little nook and
cranny on a Saturday.
Remember they taped on a Saturday and we
sparked up and we got really fucking
hot.
So now I walk in,
I got to put up with all that,
cut Judy Brown,
all that shit.
I'll say this cause I don't give a fuck.
I walk in and the guy comes and he goes
to me.
That was hilarious.
And I stopped and I go,
how can you say that to me?
How can you say that to me?
I just see you with my own eyes telling
the people what that wasn't funny and he
didn't see you when you were saying he
didn't see me.
So like,
well how can you fucking say that to me?
He goes,
I go,
as a matter of fact,
I'm going to go in there and tell John.
He goes,
you're going to go tell joe so you're
fired.
I go,
really?
Come in.
I fucking go to smack.
You don't look.
I don't give a fuck that guys are
buzzing with his fucking bike.
He's a white biker.
I'll still smack your fucking mouth.
He goes outside.
He thought he was bad to the bone with
his bike.
He's one of these bikers from Malibu.
Probably can suck my dick.
So the funny thing is he's outside by
the pipe.
That's when I went to hit him by the
pipe and he hit his head with a pipe and
we're outside and he's sitting there
like,
I'm not going back on this.
Joe is leaves you a fucking man and
you're sitting by a pipe like a little
fucking girl.
And all of a sudden,
my main man had to come up to be Jeff
sussman.
He goes,
hey man,
they don't want you to know a lot.
I might as well.
Uh,
uh,
I got to escort you off the line.
I remember I go such and walked me over
there.
And I went over there and put my hand
down and the guy wouldn't put his hand
and I go,
fuck you bitch.
And he just looked at me like he was a
tough guy with his friends.
And I remember he looked at the security
guard to throw me out.
He listened.
The security guard,
the security guard is like,
we just smoked a joint.
Yeah,
got his back.
It was very unfortunate.
He was very political
and very,
very deceptive.
He did.
No,
he didn't.
He didn't,
he,
we,
we fucked up.
I fucked up in a bunch of stuff.
You're always on that show.
But I fucked up with him.
I did not know he was that guy.
I thought he was a different guy.
You know,
he do.
Once he got in,
he wanted to do it his way.
He decided that he was running shit and
it was a real.
Remember the day,
day,
one,
day one,
we walk in and we already have.
We think that we have two episodes
already done.
Look,
we've done all these sketches.
That's about two episodes worth.
So we walked in,
we said,
he goes,
we got these all these episodes ready to
go.
Let's do them.
They said,
no,
you've got to write some new shit that.
Forget about that.
That's too crazy.
We're not going to do that shit.
Start over.
So right.
Well,
it's not that simple.
There was a bunch of sketches they had
already prepared.
Of course.
That's Dave fucking won and they won.
They put me in a room with Chris Mcguire
and they go write some jokes about
Miami.
We're going to go to Miami.
So now I am.
I am.
I feel like I'm at high school all day.
We're trying to come up with these
ideas.
I'm like,
fuck,
we have all these other ideas that are.
What the fuck are we write down new like
this is day one,
the first hour.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
By the time that nightmare day ended,
Joe was there all day too.
I go gentle man.
I just can't fucking right here.
They're ignoring all the other sketches
that we did.
And you were like,
yeah man,
I can't right here though.
I mean I had a writer's block here too.
It's just not the right environment.
So that day you told Janice and the
producers,
hey,
me and Eddie,
you're going to write at home.
We're gonna relax.
That's when all the creative juices come
out.
They said,
go ahead and get the fuck out of here.
We'll still pay him.
They just wanted to get rid of me.
So they,
I only worked there the first day and
all after that was working at home.
My job was um,
you know,
we got together a lot too,
but he was really busy with fear factor.
So if we couldn't get together,
I'd ride it home.
I'd have to have at least one sketch a
day.
So I'm at home.
Meanwhile I'm training,
I'm training for Abu Dhabi going,
oh my God,
this is not what I thought it was going
to be.
Fuck,
I just quit my strip job,
a club or Mr Club,
job strip,
Dj job for 10 years now,
and I know this isn't gonna last day
one's a disaster.
I'm like,
oh my God.
Either the shows shows going to get
canceled because they were green
lighting a bunch of bullshit and every
now and then occasionally someone would
be funny,
like the decap attack thing,
the ducks ducks down.
Hope.
That was hilarious to
what that show was.
We needed to have control of it.
Doug had to have control of it and we
had to have an appraiser that was on the
same page and the other problem we have
with that shows that it was the man
show.
We should have been doing our own show.
We should not have been taken over
someone else's show.
That's stupid.
To me.
It was like a prepackaged show that was
like.
It was easy.
It was like know have been on fear
factor.
I didn't really have the time to put
something together so this way it'd be
all put together,
but it was a mistake and it was
disrespectful to those guys at Jimmy
Kimmel and Adam curl.
I didn't even think it was at the time.
I thought they had amicably parted ways
because Jimmy wanted to do is talk show
and Adam wanted to do his thing,
but that wasn't the case.
They didn't want the show to continue.
They didn't want anybody else to do it
and it was there a thing really.
So we shouldn't have done it.
The first question,
you know,
I love it on my heart.
What is the air conditioner close by
dog?
It was like a fucking yoga class in the
hallway.
I can't go out in the hallway.
We're going to end it with a couple of
minutes anyway.
I'm not sweating.
It all got sweat on your fucking load or
it's just that shining too.
She's got makeup on Cock sucker.
I got glistening.
God put some oils.
I would have pulled up.
Look slippery.
What time is it?
It's almost 5:00
or 4:00
rather.
Oh,
you want me to go to for 20 symbolically
when NSF for 27,
whatever.
Hanging in there with 20 slash 20
minutes without air conditioning.
It's too fucking hot.
Fuck.
Think about what Mccain went through and
I'm you fucking Cock sucker.
That was his choice.
You know what I'm saying?
I came up here to a house.
I,
you had the era,
man.
We didn't even really talk about the UFC
Let's do it.
What the fuck?
Oh yeah.
Mo.
We might as well write this.
What'd you think about bj and frankie
edgar?
I thought,
you know bj,
um,
the game plan,
like when they were,
when they were in between corners,
they didn't seem to have a game plan.
The game plan was like kick his ass,
you know,
the game plan was like,
what?
There was no leg kicks,
you know?
I mean I want to see way more leg kicks.
I thought he could land leg kicks.
He's landing on man.
Every one of those leg kicks takes the
spring out of your step.
You're dealing with a guy who can't.
You can't catch him.
He's so fast.
Frankie edgar's old.
Lightening bolt,
he's all over the place.
Yeah,
he's too fast,
but he was able to land lake kicks.
Bj landed a bunch of pancakes When he
tried,
but the attempts to board,
not that many.
I know it takes a lot of energy,
but he should have been thrown a lot
more leg kicks.
I think bj tried his fucking ass off.
Look at the fifth round.
He went after him.
I just think frankie,
frankie,
edgar,
is that good?
Oh,
no doubt.
So fast.
He never gets tired.
He could do 25 rounds so fast.
His wrestling is top notch.
His striking is amazing.
He's hard to hit.
He's hard to get ahold of not taking
anything away from frankie.
I just stopped bj's game plan,
the game plan that I don't agree with.
His advice,
the advice in the corner.
I don't know.
It wasn't any advice.
They were just giving whatever kick his
ass or whatever that it.
Whatever you want to call.
I don't know this from that,
but that last two fights against
whatever.
That was not the same guy seen against
diego sanchez.
There's something more that.
Yeah,
it could Be a lack of motivation.
That could be,
you know,
he needs to mix things up.
Well,
the difference between the camp,
the difference between frankie edgar
standup and dig a sanchez standard.
It's a huge difference to his head,
but you don't have the cj hurt diego
early on a fight that fight was,
it was perfect.
So I didn't have any Fucking tenacity.
And the dj was gonna to frankie bEcause
frankie edgar counters that tenacity
with his speed.
It could be the bj get frustrated and
you know,
he loses,
he gets a little disheartened and
amazing wrestler with serious standard
because for the longest time bj had the
best hands.
That lightweight.
No one was fucking with bj.
He was the best boxer.
Now frankie edgar,
it looks like his technique.
I mean,
it's totally different,
but it seems like he's just too fast,
too good.
He's working too hard and I think,
uh,
you know,
maybe be jay might,
um,
you know,
a switch,
like you mentioned,
a switch of camps maybe might not hurt
add anything new or something fake
jaegers kicking it to a whole nother
level athletically.
Speed,
endurance wise,
the way he can move his training camp
must be insane.
You should fucking worker machine.
He's one of those little dudes you can't
fuck with someone has been fucking with
him all of his life and he built up a
level of tenacity that not that many
people can handle.
This mentality is fucking perfect.
Randy couture's mentality,
you know what I mean?
And It's cardio and his endurance and
his will.
But you know,
if you look at like the way he moves,
he moves better than random.
Sure.
I'm talking about the mental game and
you know,
people were saying,
oh,
he's not stopping people.
He stopped stopping.
Some people,
which you have to realize though,
is he's quite a bit smaller than
everybody else in the division.
He's 154 pounds for real.
Legit.
I think ultimately he's throwing with
with evil intentions.
He just hasn't developed the power yet,
But I believe,
you know,
within the next couple of years,
two,
three years,
maybe five years,
he's going to be crushing people because
he comes in,
he comes in to blast 100 percent now
with pj heard veech and veatch is a
tough guy,
you know,
and he,
he dropped him before he strangled him
and you know,
his standup when he was fighting with
sean cherokee.
He totally kickbox sean.
Sure.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker,
dude.
It's going to be interesting.
No,
the rematch with gray maynard,
that's going to be very interesting,
very interesting.
Enters a hard guy to beat male.
You know,
you can complain all you want about his
style.
The problem is he presents problems.
What's the solution to that problem?
You've got to be able to stop it from
taking you down,
man.
He's a powerful motherfucker and he's a
good wrestler.
All you got to have a wicked fucking
dustin hayzlett guard or something,
you know,
even more than more wicked than dustin
hazy.
It's really right because dustin
hayzlett couldn't do shit against were
story.
You know,
it's more,
he needs like some fucking a.
Okay,
well he's going down to 55 because he
should be there.
Ricky story was three times stronger
than dustin hayzlett.
Right.
but,
so,
you know,
josh brooklyn's strongest fucked too.
And dustin had no problem with him.
Yeah.
But I think ricky story is stronger than
josh burke.
He went out,
he's from Washington and he's rolled to
gerald,
one of my black belts a lot and gerald,
he calls me to tell me about the roles
with,
with uh,
ricky story.
He said he's fucking amazing.
These are so powerful and good.
Very technical.
You know,
you're going to see him start to develop
some finishing too.
He's all into evolving and adding
weapons to his game constantly.
And he's young and he's his fucking
mental game.
That guy goes in there and fucking he
loves to destroy,
to when take it up against the cage and
started ripping his body with punches
like,
oh,
it's very hard to deal with.
He's doing everything he could just to
stay alive.
This scott was just crushing him with
punches.
Boom.
I was thinking about randy and tyler.
Frankie edgar might need to go ahead,
finish what you were saying.
Frankie edgar might really need to,
um,
uh,
take his game to the next level.
I was impressed with him off his back,
man.
I was impressed at how he recovered when
bj,
bj amounts of them got a hold of him and
your dad when bj mount to.
It's usually over frankie.
Just shit fucking.
He's got so much energy,
man.
He could just keep pushing,
keep pushing.
He doesn't give up,
man does not give up.
You know,
some guys rest.
If bj mounted your rest and you're like,
oh fuck,
now I got to get out of this,
but let me bide my time for a big
explosion.
Frankie,
The moment he got taken down with move,
move,
move.
I'm out.
You know,
obviously bj's card wasn't good enough
to really threaten a frankie edgar.
Really?
I mean,
frankie edgar has great defenses.
Jujitsu is awesome too,
but what I did like about bj is his
guard recovery,
his butterflies and his foot on the hip
control.
God damn,
it was really beautiful to see and
again,
you know,
um,
he didn't really talk that much office
back.
Uh,
but his recovery just amazing.
He really uses his flexibility.
Well,
and when he had both his hips on frankie
had both his feet on frankie's hips at
serious,
amazing yoda control,
you know,
y'all know he's bad ass and controlling
guys like that,
but not enough to finish guys.
It's weird that bj such a jujitsu
master,
but yet he doesn't really finish guys
off of his back.
He's had problems in a lot of fights.
Regards can take them down and hold them
down.
You know,
that was obviously the problem that
george st pierre fight and that was
obviously the problem when frankie edgar
took him down to a problem that is
prevalent in.